THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
NOW. GOOD AFTERNOON. WE WILL. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE Þ STREET
BUILDING. AND I ASK THAT ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMITTEE COME
FORWARD TO BE PRESENT IN ROOM
2200 SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING. WE HAVE 22 BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA, AND EIGHT OF
THOSE WILL BE ON THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR, ABSENT OF A
QUORUM, WE WILL MOVE FORWARD AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND I DO HAVE A
FEW BILLS THAT WE WILL BE HEARD,
HEARD, OUT OF FILE ORDER.
OTHERWISE WE WILL BE IN FILE
ORDER AFTER OUR FIRST TWO
PRESENTERS. OKAY. OUR FIRST
AUTHOR TODAY. WELCOME, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. AND WE WILL BE HEARING
ASSEMBLY BILL 3229 AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AS WE WAIT FOR OUR
QUORUM. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES WITH YOU HERE TODAY?
IF YOU DO, WE WILL ASK THAT THEY
COME FORWARD TO THE CONFERENCE
TABLE, PLEASE. AT THE CONFERENCE
TABLE WOULD BE GREAT, AND WE'LL
JUST HAVE YOU REMAIN THERE UNTIL
WE THANK YOU. ADDRESS. ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS? OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE, WHEN YOU'RE
READY. SURE. WELL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. I APPRECIATE
MAKING ACCOMMODATION AS WELL.
FIRST, I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL, AND I
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS TO MOVE
THE REPORTING DATE TO JULY 1ST,
2025. I UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL NEED TO BE TAKEN
AT THE NEXT STEP IN THE PROCESS,
AND I COMMIT TO DOING SO.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3229 WOULD COMBINE
REPORTING DEADLINES FOR TWO
LEGISLATIVE REPORTS ON THE
CALIFORNIA FRUIT AND VEGETABLE
EBT PILOT PROGRAM, SPECIFICALLY
THIS. THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
RESULTS OF THE EVALUATION
ORIGINALLY DUE SEPTEMBER 1ST,
2025, AND THE SCOPING PLAN TO
TRANSITION THE PILOT PROJECT
INTO A PERMANENT PROGRAM.
ORIGINALLY DUE MARCH 1ST, 2026,
TO BE SUBMITTED NO LATER THAN
JULY 1ST, 2025, WHEN THE AMENDS
ARE ADOPTED AS WE KNOW NOW,
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD YET ABOUT 8
MILLION CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLE
WITH FOOD INSECURITY. THAT'S 20%
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION THAT
GO HUNGRY EVERY DAY, INCLUDING
CHILDREN. PART OF THE REASON FOR
THIS INCREASED COST OF LIVING
THAT MAKE IT HARD TO ACCESS
AFFORDABLE, NUTRITIOUS FOOD TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE, THE
CALIFORNIA FRUIT AND VEGETABLE
EBT PILOT PROJECT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN 2018 AIMED AT
BOOSTING THE PURCHASE AND
CONSUMPTION OF FRESH FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES TO CALFRESH
BENEFICIARIES. THE PILOT PROGRAM
PROVIDED UP TO $60 IN
NUTRITIONAL INCENTIVES A MONTH
FOR EVERY $1 OF CALFRESH SPENT
ON ANY FRUIT AND VEGETABLE, A
RECIPIENT GOT BACK $1 TO SPEND
ON ANY CALFRESH ELIGIBLE FOOD.
AS OF FEBRUARY 2024, THE PILOT
OPERATED AT 87 GROCERY STORES
AND NUMEROUS FARMERS MARKETS
ACROSS THE STATE, PROVIDING $1.9
MILLION IN REBATES FOR FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES TO 75,000
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS 44 COUNTIES.
DESPITE ITS SUCCESS, THOUGH, THE
PILOT ENDED IN APRIL 2024 DUE TO
THE MONEY RUNNING OUT. EVEN
THOUGH THE SUNSET OF THE PILOT
WAS ORIGINALLY IN JANUARY 1ST,
2027, RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
SIMILAR PROGRAMS REDUCE HUNGER,
IMPROVE HEALTH, AND INCREASE
REVENUE FOR AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE FAMILIES
CONTINUE TO BENEFITED FROM THE
EBT PILOT IN THE COMING YEARS,
AB 3229 AIMS TO ADVANCE THE
REPORTING DEADLINES FOR BOTH THE
EVALUATION REPORT AND THE
SCOPING PLAN WITH ME IN SUPPORT
OF AB 32 3029 IS JARED CALL ON
BEHALF OF NOURISH CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE. THANK YOU,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, AS YOU SAID,
JARED, CALL WITH NOURISH
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF. BEFORE YOU START
QUICKLY, I JUST WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW YOU'LL HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
PRESENT IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE PROUD CO-SPONSORS OF AB
3229, ALONG WITH FULL WELL. AND
WE ACTUALLY HELPED DESIGN THE
PROJECT FROM THE GROUND UP
BEGINNING BACK IN 2018. SO
AGAIN, WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE. AS HE
SAID, WE HAVE A VERY EFFECTIVE,
EFFICIENT PROGRAM RIGHT NOW AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT RELIES ON THE
NORMAL CHANNELS OF COMMERCE AND
OUR VERY EFFICIENT ELECTRONIC
BENEFIT TRANSFER SYSTEM TO GET
EXTRA FOOD ONTO PEOPLE'S TABLES
IN THE FORM OF PRIMARILY FRESH,
CALIFORNIA GROWN FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES. UP TO $60 IN REBATES
EACH MONTH, AGAIN, AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HIGHLIGHTED,
WE'VE GOT VERY TROUBLING LEVELS
OF FOOD INSECURITY IN THE STATE,
AND THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM THAT, AGAIN,
HAS VERY LITTLE OVERHEAD, 95 TO
97% OF THE FUNDING IS BENEFITS.
THAT IS FOOD ON THE TABLE,
AGAIN, BECAUSE IT RELIES ON THE
NORMAL CHANNELS OF COMMERCE.
THERE'S NO COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION, THERE'S NO
APPLICATIONS. PEOPLE GO, THEY
SHOP, THEY GET THE FOOD THEY
WANT, AND THEY GET A LITTLE
BREAK ON THE PRICE. AT ITS PEAK
IN MARCH 2024, THE PROGRAM WAS
SERVING 55,000 CALFRESH
HOUSEHOLDS AND REDEEMING OVER
$2.5 MILLION IN FRUITS AND
VEGETABLE SUPPLEMENTS ALONE. WE
HAVE HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
TESTIMONIALS FROM VERY SATISFIED
AND HAPPY SHOPPERS WHO WANT TO
SEE THIS PROGRAM CONTINUE TO
RETURN AND EXPAND. SO AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EXPLAINED, AND
AS THE COMMITTEE IS AWARE, THE
PROGRAM DID RUN OUT OF FUNDING
AND WAS PAUSED IN APRIL OF THIS
YEAR. BUT WE NEED THESE REPORTS
AND THIS INFORMATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO WE CAN PLAN TO
TURN THAT VERY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM BACK ON AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. SO AGAIN, WE'RE ALSO
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND THE DEPARTMENT TO ACCEPT
THOSE AMENDMENTS. BUT WE DO WANT
TO SEE THOSE REPORTS PRODUCED AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE SO WE CAN GET
THIS BACK ON TRACK. THANK YOU.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT. DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT? PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE
WITH YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION ONLY, PLEASE.
YEAH. MARTIN RADOSEVICH, ON
BEHALF OF FOLWELL, PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AARON EVANS, ON
BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. REBECCA GONZALEZ
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL? WE WILL HEAR YOU
NOW. OKAY. SEEING NONE, ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION. OKAY.
WE'LL BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. NOW, AS
YOU SEE, MY COLLEAGUES ARE
EITHER PRESENTING IN OTHER,
OTHER COMMITTEES OR WORKING
THEIR WAY OVER HERE, BUT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE, I JUST
WANTED YOU TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
AROUND THE REPORTS. I KNOW THAT
THE TIMING IS CRITICAL. WE WANT
THOSE REPORTS TO COME IN, ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT THAT WE
ENGAGED IN WAS AROUND, WHAT IS
THE CONSEQUENCE OF CDSS DOES NOT
SUBMIT THESE REPORTS ON TIME AS
YOUR BILL SUGGESTS, HOW CAN WE
ENSURE HOW CAN WE ASSURE THAT
THERE IS FOLLOW UP AND ADHERENCE
TO WHAT YOU'RE ASKING THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO, WELL, I'LL
TURN OVER TO MY SPONSOR IN A
SECOND. BUT I DO THINK THAT, YOU
KNOW, ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE THE
COUNTERPART CHAIRS FOR HUMAN
SERVICES, IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT, OF COURSE, WE
HAVE OUR WILL IMPLEMENTED
THROUGH THE LEGISLATION PASSED,
BUT ALSO TO EXERCISE THE
OVERSIGHT ABILITY, IF POSSIBLE.
THIS IS A WILDLY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM THAT'S VERY FRICTIONLESS
FOR THE CONSUMER. AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THE DATA
TO BACK IT UP, THAT WE CONTINUE
FORWARD. I DON'T KNOW IF, JARED,
YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD TO
THAT. SURE. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE. JARED
COLLIGAN FROM NOURISH
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT IN OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AND IN TESTIFYING
AT BUDGET COMMITTEES, YOU KNOW,
THIS SPRING, THE DEPARTMENT
LIKES THE PROGRAM. THERE'S NO
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE. IT REALLY
IS JUST THIS FUNDING ISSUE, AND
WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT GOING ON
AT THE DEPARTMENT. SUNBOX IS
ROLLING OUT A LOT OF OTHER VERY
EXCITING PROGRAMS. BUT GIVEN
THAT THIS ONE HAS BEEN AROUND
SINCE 2018 AND IS SO
PHENOMENALLY SUCCESSFUL AND HAS
VERY LITTLE, AGAIN,
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AT ALL,
WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL AND CONFIDENT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT WILL WILL
RESPOND TO THIS LEGISLATION AND
FULFILL THAT THAT NEED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
ANYTHING THAT I CAN DO TO HELP
SUPPORT YOU ON OUR END AS WELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, CHAIRMAN LEE,
WE ARE GOING TO ABSENT OF
QUORUM. WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS
THIS. THIS BILL WHEN WE'RE ABLE
TO DO THAT. OKAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
BEFORE WE, MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
BILL, I WILL ASK BROUGH AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. DO WE
HAVE BRIGHT HERE ON HIS WAY.
OKAY ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. WE
ARE GOING TO BE MOVING IN FILE
ORDER. SO I ASK THAT ALL OF OUR
AUTHORS, START TO MOVE THEIR WAY
DOWN TO ROOM 2200 SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE DOWN TODAY'S DOCKET, I
DO SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NGUYEN
HERE. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE,
SO WE WILL GO TO ITEM NUMBER,
FIVE. OOPS. NO WE WANT TO GO TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX, ASSEMBLY BILL
2317. ASSEMBLY MEMBER NGUYEN.
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. I'M HERE TO PROUDLY
PRESENT AB 2317, ALSO KNOWN AS
ELIJAH'S LAW, WHICH PROTECTS
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN WHO ATTEND
CHILD CARE FROM THIS LIFE
THREATENING BUT TREATABLE
CONDITION. ANAPHYLAXIS IS A
SEVERE ALLERGIC REACTION THAT
REQUIRES IMMEDIATE MEDICAL
ATTENTION AND CAN LEAD TO DEATH.
MANY OF US WHO ARE PARENTS, OR
MANY OF US NOWADAYS, ALSO HAVE
AN ALLERGIC REACTION TO SEVERAL
DIFFERENT THINGS. I'VE GOT A
KIDDO WHO'S ALLERGIC TO SEAFOOD
TO DAIRY, TO EGG, TO TREES, TO
GRASS, TO AIR, BASICALLY, AND
LUCKILY SHE'S GROWN OUT OF IT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, AS YOU SEND YOUR
KIDDO OFF TO DAYCARE RIGHT NOW,
THERE ISN'T A PLAN IN PLACE. AB
2317 REQUIRES CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE ANAPHYLAXIS PLAN
IN PLACE BY 2028. AND HERE, AS A
WITNESS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
GARY RIDDLE OF KALEO, WHO IS IN
PARTNERS WITH ELIJAH'S LAW, OUR
FOUNDATION ACROSS THE NATION.
I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER FOR
HIM TO SAY A FEW WORDS. THANK
YOU. WE'LL GIVE YOU ABOUT TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT. GOT IT.
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT, MADAM
CHAIR, DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS GARY
RIDDLE OF KALEO, AND I'M HERE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THOMAS
SILVEIRA. HE'S THE CO-FOUNDER OF
THE ELIJAH ALABI FOUNDATION,
SPONSOR OF AB 2317, WHO COULD
NOT BE HERE TODAY SINCE HE
RESIDES IN THE STATE OF NEW
YORK. KALEO HAS PARTNERED WITH
THE ELIJAH ALAVI FOUNDATION TO
HELP PASS BILLS LIKE AB 2317
ACROSS THE NATION. MR. SILVEIRA
IS THE FATHER OF ELIJAH ALAVI
AND UNFORTUNATELY KNOWS
FIRSTHAND THE URGENT NEED FOR
COMPREHENSIVE ANAPHYLAXIS
PREPAREDNESS IN CHILD CARE
SETTINGS. ON NOVEMBER 3RD, 2017,
THOMAS'S LIFE WAS FOREVER
CHANGED WHEN HIS SON ELIJAH
TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY DUE TO AN
ANAPHYLACTIC REACTION AT A CHILD
CARE CENTER. DESPITE EXPLICIT
INSTRUCTIONS REGARDING A SEVERE
DAIRY ALLERGY, ELIJAH WAS GIVEN
A GRILLED CHEESE SANDWICH, WHICH
LED TO A FATAL ALLERGIC
REACTION. THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WERE ILL EQUIPPED TO
RECOGNIZE AND RESPOND TO THE
SIGNS OF ANAPHYLAXIS, AND
NECESSARY LIFE SAVING MEASURES
WERE NOT ADMINISTERED IN TIME.
THIS DEVASTATING LOSS HAS
HIGHLIGHTED CRITICAL GAPS IN
ALLERGY MANAGEMENT AND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS WITHIN CHILD CARE
SETTINGS ACROSS THE US. IN THE
WAKE OF THIS TRAGEDY, ELIJAH
ALAVI FOUNDATION WAS ESTABLISHED
TO HONOR ELIJAH'S MEMORY AND TO
HELP PREVENT SUCH HEARTBREAKING
INCIDENTS FROM HAPPENING TO
OTHER FAMILIES. THE FOUNDATION
IS DEDICATED TO RAISING
AWARENESS ABOUT FOOD ALLERGIES
AND ANAPHYLAXIS, ADVOCATING FOR
POLICY CHANGES SUCH AS AB 2317
AND PROVIDING EDUCATION
RESOURCES TO PARENTS,
CAREGIVERS, CAREGIVERS, AND
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB 2317 CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED. ANAPHYLAXIS A SEVERE
AND POTENTIALLY FATAL ALLERGIC
REACTION, IS ON THE RISE, WITH A
STAGGERING 316% INCREASE IN
ANAPHYLAXIS RELATED HEALTH CARE
CLAIMS IN THE PAST 12 YEARS.
YOUNG CHILDREN WERE THE LARGEST
PREPONDERANCE OF ANAPHYLAXIS IS
HAPPENING TO OCCUR, PARTICULARLY
THOSE AGED 0 TO 4 ARE ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE AS THEY MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE THEIR
SYMPTOMS. AB 2317 HELPS TO
ENSURE EVERY CHILD CARE PROVIDER
IN CALIFORNIA IS EQUIPPED WITH
THE NECESSARY TOOLS AND
KNOWLEDGE TO PREVENT, IDENTIFY
AND RESPOND TO THE ALLERGIC
ANAPHYLACTIC REACTIONS SWIFTLY
AND EFFECTIVELY, INCLUDING
GUIDELINES FOR, FOR AND ALLOWING
POTENTIAL USE OF APPROPRIATE
WEIGHT BASED DOSE OF
EPINEPHRINE. THIS POLICY WILL
SAVE PRECIOUS LIVES AND PROVIDE
PEACE OF MIND TO CAREGIVERS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON AB
2317 AND PLEASE, AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME, WE WISH FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE'LL NOW GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL 2317.
PLEASE COME FORWARD WITH YOUR
NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ONLY. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, JENNIFER
TANNEHILL WITH AARON REED AND
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY FOR
RESPIRATORY CARE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. OKAY. DO
WE HAVE ANY, WITNESSES, LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. PLEASE COME FORWARD NOW.
OKAY. SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. OKAY. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WISHING
TO ASK QUESTIONS, COMMENTS?
SENATOR MENGIBAR, THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, ASSEMBLYMAN, AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS CARRIED AN
EPIPEN ALMOST HER WHOLE LIFE,
I'VE BEEN INTUBATED. I'VE GONE
INTO A FULL, I THINK, TWICE
ALREADY, DUE TO FRUIT AND NUTS.
I UNDERSTAND THIS NEAR AND DEAR
TO MY HEART, BUT I ALSO HAVE
BEEN VERY ENGAGED WITH WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN THE CHILD CARE
SPACE AND REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THE MOVEMENT FORWARD AND SOME
STEPS BACKWARDS. I KNOW THE
BURDEN THAT IS PLACED. CAN YOU
CONFIRM WITH ME THAT YOUR BILL
IS KIND OF LIKE AN OPT IN? IF
THE CHILD CARE PROVIDER, HAS THE
ABILITY TO DO THE TRAINING AND
THEN ADMINISTER THE EPIPEN?
YEAH. AND I'M GOING TO PUT THIS
TO THE SPONSOR BECAUSE I KNOW
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH SOME OF
THOSE. THERE'S BEEN SOME
QUESTIONS, AMENDMENTS BEING
ASKED TO BE TAKEN. I'M GOING TO
LET THE SPONSOR KIND OF GO INTO
DETAILS ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY NO. AN OPT IN
APPROACH IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT IS WELL UNDERSTOOD. IS THAT
IN THE BILL RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE I
WAS JUST TRYING TO GET CLARITY
BECAUSE SOME WORDS SAY MAY SURE
PARTICIPATE. SO I JUST WANTED TO
HEAR IT STRAIGHT FROM THE
SOURCE. I BELIEVE THAT CERTAINLY
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THE PARTIES AT HAND THAT ARE
WEIGHING IN ON THIS BILL, SUCH
AS CDSS AND CDE, ETC. AND THAT
IS THE THAT IS THE DIRECTION
THAT WE'RE PURSUING IS AN OPT IN
APPROACH. BUT SO CURRENTLY IN
PRINT RIGHT NOW, IT'S A
REQUIREMENT FOR EVERYONE TO TAKE
THE TRAINING. OKAY. IT'S A MAY
RIGHT NOW ACCORDING TO THE BILL
LANGUAGE OKAY. YES. SO IT'S
STILL IT'S STILL VOLUNTARILY.
THAT'S CORRECT. I THINK YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR THE ACTUAL DETAILS
OF IT SAYING THAT IT'S AN OPT
IN, RIGHT? YES. AND SO I KNOW
THAT THEY'VE REACHED OUT AND
WE'RE TRYING TO HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE, AS WHAT
YOU HAD MENTIONED, TO MAKE SURE
IT WORKS WITH WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING. AND YOU KNOW, I
UNDERSTAND DAYCARE PROVIDERS.
THERE'S A LOT OF REQUIREMENTS,
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
THEY HAVE TO PUT IN PLACE. AND
WE DEFINITELY DON'T WANT TO PUT
THIS AS A BURDEN ON A LOT OF
THESE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. BUT
BUT FOR THOSE RIGHT, THAT HAVE
KIDDOS THAT DO HAVE ALLERGIC
REACTION, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE ALSO FULLY
EQUIPPED AND THEY HAVE A PLAN IN
PLACE JUST IN CASE IT IS NEEDED.
THANK YOU. SO MY MEMBER, THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR CLARIFICATION. ARE
THESE PLANS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
MADE INDEPENDENTLY FOR EACH
SITE, OR ARE YOU ARE YOU LOOKING
FOR SOME TYPE OF STANDARD OF
CARE THAT THE CHILD CARE CENTERS
CAN ADOPT? I THINK WE'RE STILL
WORKING THROUGH THOSE DETAILS.
I'LL CERTAINLY LET THE SPONSOR
ANSWER THAT IN DETAILS, IF.
SURE. ABSOLUTELY. I MEAN, THE
BEST APPROACH ALWAYS WOULD BE
SOME SORT OF STATEWIDE
GUIDELINES THAT ARE THEN, YOU
KNOW, BASICALLY DEVELOPED
BETWEEN THE PARTIES. RIGHT?
RIGHT, ABSOLUTELY. AND IN YOUR
BILL, YOU DO HAVE A GROUP OF
PARTIES THAT WILL BE CONSULTED,
INCLUDING, SOME OF OUR LABOR
PARTNERS. HOW DO YOU SEE THE
TIMELINE IN THIS BILL DEVELOPING
SO THAT ALL MEMBERS AT THE TABLE
ARE ALIGNED ON, ON WHAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION LOOKS LIKE? SURE.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS GET THIS OUT OF
COMMITTEE FIRST AND PASS, AND
THEN PULL EVERYBODY TOGETHER TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DOES THIS LOOK
LIKE. AS YOU MENTIONED, THERE
ARE A LOT OF PARTIES INVOLVED
WITH THIS. THERE IS NO ONE SIZE
FITS ALL, AND I THINK WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
A PLAN IN PLACE. RIGHT. THERE IS
AN ACTUAL PLAN THAT'S IN PLACE
IN CASE IT IS NEEDED. BUT WE ARE
AWARE THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WANT TO BE AT
THE TABLE, A LOT OF ENTITIES, A
LOT OF GROUPS, A LOT OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT REALLY CARE
ABOUT THIS. AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT WORKS ALL ACROSS.
AND SO THAT IS DEFINITELY A
CONVERSATION THAT IS ONGOING.
AND WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS A PLAN IN PLACE
RIGHT NOW. THERE ISN'T A PLAN IN
PLACE. AND SO THE FIRST STEP IS
TO LET'S MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING TO SAY, THAT THERE IS
A PLAN IN PLACE IN CASE THIS
HAPPENS. I THINK THAT IS THE
FIRST STEP. AFTER THAT, IT'S
LET'S PULL EVERYBODY TOGETHER TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS THE PLAN, HOW
DOES THIS WORK? THERE IS ONCE
AGAIN, NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL, BUT
THERE ARE GOING TO BE CERTAIN
CENTERS THAT MAY NEED MORE THAN
OTHERS AS WELL. AND MAYBE SOME
CENTERS WILL SAY THAT THEY
AREN'T ABLE AND EQUIPPED TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE IN KIDDOS THAT HAVE
ALLERGIC REACTION OR WHATNOT. WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO SAY THAT
THAT'S OKAY, RIGHT? BUT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A
PLAN IN PLACE FOR THOSE THAT,
COME ACROSS SUCH A SITUATION TO
AVOID ANY TRAGEDIES. RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM JUST YET,
BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. AYE VOTE
WHEN THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE.
RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MEMBER
NGUYEN. AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. RIGHT. OKAY. SO LOOKING
FOR AUTHORS, GOING BACK INTO
FILE ORDER. OH SOMETHING MEMBER
JACKSON WILL INVITE YOU TO COME
AND PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL, ITEM
NUMBER TWO, ASSEMBLY BILL 772.
WHEN YOU'RE READY, IF YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES WITH YOU HERE
TODAY, WE'LL HAVE THEM COME UP
FRONT. SURE, AB 772, IS A BILL
TO CLARIFY AND MAKE IT EASIER
FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN NEED OF
CHILD CARE TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
IT, AB 775 FIRST OF ALL, I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS. BY THE WAY, THANK
YOU SO MUCH, CASE. YOU'RE
WONDERING, NOW CLARIFIES UPON
ADMISSION OF A CHILD INTO A DROP
IN CHILD CARE CENTER IF A
MEDICAL ASSESSMENT IS NOT
AVAILABLE FOR A CHILD AS
REQUIRED BY THE DEPARTMENT
REGULATIONS, AND THE LICENSEE
SHALL OBTAIN A WRITTEN HEALTH
ASSESSMENT COMPLETED BY THE
CHILD'S AUTHORIZED
REPRESENTATIVE. THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE THE CHILD'S
AUTHORIZED REPRESENTATIVE TO
SIGN ACKNOWLEDGMENT FORMS. THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT VERIFICATION OF
IMMUNIZATIONS AND TUBERCULOSIS
TESTING IS NOT REQUIRED FOR ANY
CHILD ACCEPTED INTO A DROP IN
CHILD CARE CENTER. RESPECTFULLY,
AS FOR YOUR I VOTE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ANY LEAD WITNESSES WITH
YOU HERE TODAY? NOPE. OKAY.
WE'LL GIVE OPPORTUNITY TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO COME
FORWARD AND SHARE THEIR
POSITION, NAME AND AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ONLY. PLEASE GOOD
AFTERNOON, MCKENZIE RICHARDSON
WITH THRIVING FAMILIES
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. OKAY. ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THAT
WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD TODAY
OKAY. SEEING NONE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE
HEARD IN OPPOSITION. OKAY. WE'LL
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS YEAH. ALL RIGHT. LOOKS
LIKE THERE'S GOING TO BE QUICK
FOR YOU. THAT'S HOW I ROLL. ALL
RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AND THEN WE WILL ADDRESS THE
VOTE WHEN WE GET A FULL QUORUM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU
HAVE ANOTHER BILL IN FRONT OF US
TODAY I DO. ALL RIGHT. SO AB
1967, IF I MAY, MADAM CHAIR,
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. ITEM NUMBER
FOUR. HEY I DO HAVE BACKUP FOR
THIS. ALL RIGHT, AB 1967 SEEKS
TO CREATE A FOOD AND SECURITY
OFFICER WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES,
TASKED WITH COORDINATING AND
ADDRESSING FOOD INSECURITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS, WE ALSO KNOW THAT
TOO MANY FOR TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS, WE ARE STILL
FACING, TOO MANY OF OUR
POPULATION WITH FOOD INSECURITY,
AND USUALLY THE THING THAT GIVES
US THE RED FLAG FIRST IS USUALLY
WHEN WE BEGIN TO SEE OUR FOOD
BANKS BEGIN TO DEPLETE. BUT THAT
SHOULD NOT BE THE ONLY THING
THAT CAUSES US TO REACT. WE NEED
A MORE COORDINATED PLAN WITH
SOMEONE IN THE STATE THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
PEOPLE ARE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR,
SNAP AND ANY OTHER ASSISTANCE,
THAT THERE'S A PLAN TO HELP THEM
GET ENROLLED. LET THEM GET,
BECAUSE THERE'S TOO MANY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS GOING,
UNUTILIZED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, WHEN PEOPLE, ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR ACCESS FOR THIS
FOOD SUPPORT TODAY IS WE HAVE
MARSHAWN TATMAN, TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO FOOD
BANK. OKAY. YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO PRESENT.
ABSOLUTELY. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
MARSHAWN TABERNA. I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
ADVOCACY AT THE SAN FRANCISCO
MARIN FOOD BANK. AND ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL, MY FAMILY AND I
ONCE STRUGGLE WITH FOOD
INSECURITY GROWING UP SO THIS
ISSUE IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART. I'M HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
AS A CO-SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF AB
1967, WHICH WOULD CREATE A
CABINET LEVEL POSITION DEDICATED
TO ENDING HUNGER IN CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES AND ACKNOWLEDGING
THESE POTENTIALLY TURBULENT
YEARS AHEAD OF US, CALIFORNIA IS
STILL THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY. HOWEVER, THE WEALTH IS
NOT TRANSFERRING TO THE MANY
STRUGGLING BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
FOOD INSECURITY RATE IS
ESTIMATED AT 1 IN 4
CALIFORNIANS. YET 34% OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT RECEIVING
CALFRESH. WE ARE FALLING AND
FAILING TO MEET THE POTENTIAL OF
THIS CRITICAL ANTI-POVERTY
BENEFIT, LEAVING 2.7 BILLION ON
THE TABLE IN FEDERAL BENEFITS.
CALFRESH, FORMERLY KNOWN AS FOOD
STAMPS, PROVIDE VITAL ASSISTANCE
TO LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILY SETS IN NUTRITION, FOOD
ARE A FOOD AT THEIR CHOICE, BUT
THE RISING COST NECESSITIES ARE
FORCING DIFFICULT TRADEOFFS. ON
AVERAGE, MORE THAN ONE OUT OF
FOUR CALIFORNIANS FACES
UNCERTAINTY OR INCONSISTENT
ACCESS TO FOOD. AND YET THE
NUMBER DOESN'T TELL THE FULL
STORY. WE USUALLY SEE THIS
HAPPENING IN, BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES, BIPOC COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE A POWERFUL ANTI-HUNGER
TOOL AT OUR DISPOSAL IN THE
CALFRESH PROGRAM THAT HELP
PROVIDE VITAL FOOD, BUT WE'RE
NOT USING IT TO THE BEST OF ITS
ABILITY YET. CALIFORNIA'S SIX TO
LAST IN ALL STATES IN CALFRESH
PARTICIPATION, WITH ONLY 66%
COMPARED TO THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
OF 77. NEW MEXICO, PENNSYLVANIA,
OREGON ALL HAVE 100% CALFRESH
PARTICIPATION RATES, AND THIS
SEVEN MORE STATES THAT ALSO HAVE
100% SO IT CAN GET DONE. NOW,
WHY CAN'T PROGRESS BE MADE,
AMONG OTHER THINGS, AND
RESPECTFULLY, POLITICAL WILL
SILOS AND EFFORTS THAT'S NOT
ALIGNED BETWEEN THE STATE
DEPARTMENTS IN ADDITION TO
CALFRESH, THERE ARE A MYRIAD OF
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO INCREASE
NUTRITION AND HEALTH AND TO
REDUCE HUNGER ACROSS A GROWING
NUMBER OF STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES. I THINK IT'S AROUND
SEVEN OF THEM. HOWEVER, WE DON'T
HAVE AN ACCOUNTABLE LEADER FOR
RESULTS WE DESIRE AND A LACK OF
ALIGNMENT AND COORDINATION. LIKE
I SAID, FOLKS BEEN DOING
INCREDIBLE WORK, BUT CALIFORNIA
IS STILL FACING A LOT OF FOOD
INSECURITY. 1 IN 4 CALIFORNIANS
A NEW APPROACH IS NEEDED. THE
CREATION OF A CABINET LEVEL
POSITION WOULD ENSURE POLICY
ALIGNMENT, IMPLEMENTATION,
OPTIMIZATION, AND OUTCOME
RESOURCES BETWEEN DIVERSE
DEPARTMENTS. WE NEED TO INVEST
IN SOLUTIONS THAT REDUCE
BARRIERS TO ACCESS THESE
PROGRAMS AND SOLUTIONS TO
INCREASE COLLABORATION AND
ALIGNMENT BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE STATE.
THIS APPROACH IS PROVEN IN
STATES LIKE MAINE AND NEW
JERSEY, WHICH EACH CREATED A
CABINET LEVEL LEADER POSITION TO
ADDRESS FOOD INSECURITY. WE KNOW
POVERTY IS THE ROOT CAUSE OF
HUNGER, AND WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
IGNORE A SOLUTION THAT CAN
PROFOUNDLY CHANGE IT. THANK YOU,
AND WE APPRECIATE THE I VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME FORWARD
WITH YOUR NAME, ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION. CHER GONZALEZ ON
BY BEHALF OF MY CLIENT, THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION,
WE ARE A PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF THE
BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. JONATHAN MUNOZ ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT AND WE THANK
DOCTOR JACKSON FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, DYLAN ELLIOTT,
ON BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR
LONDON BREED, AS WELL AS THE
COUNTY OF MARIN, BOTH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HERE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, JOHNNY
VILLE, WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
ANDREA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND SUPPORT, THANK YOU.
COREY SMITH, ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION, FOOD,
SHELTER, WATER, THE BASICS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI, JUSTIN BOWERS, CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS ORG STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
IN ADDITION, THE NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE FACTS ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND NCCA
ALSO SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT. ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
ASSEMBLY BILL 1967? PLEASE COME
FORWARD. OKAY. SEEING NONE, ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION. I'D
LIKE TO BE HEARD. OKAY. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS? COMMENTS
THANK. BIG SMILES ON THIS SIDE,
DOCTOR JACKSON, I JUST I HAVE TO
POINT OUT. SO WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE THE GOVERNOR APPOINTMENT
POWER TO YET ANOTHER, A HIGH
LEVEL POSITION. HOW ARE WE GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE AS
LEGISLATORS HOLD THIS PERSON
ACCOUNTABLE, OR THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH ACCOUNTABLE FOR THESE
GOALS THAT MUST BE MET? LIKE WE
CAN'T. WE CAN'T LET ANY CRACKS
IN THIS, IN THIS CEMENT HAPPEN.
WELL, I THINK THE BEST THE ONLY
THING THAT I CAN THINK OF IS TO
MAKING SURE THAT IN THIS
APPOINTMENT THAT THE SENATE CAN
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS IN TERMS
OF OR THEIR PURVIEW, TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE A
PART OF THAT APPOINTMENT PROCESS
LIKE YOU DO OTHER POSITIONS AS
WELL. AND SO WE'D LOVE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON LANGUAGE, IF
THAT YOU BELIEVE THAT'S GOING TO
BE ANOTHER CHECK AND BALANCE SO
THAT WE CAN DO THIS. I MEAN, THE
IDEA IS THIS IS THAT WE CAN'T
THIS CAN'T JUST BE A BOX TO
CHECK OFF. THAT'S RIGHT. THIS
CAN'T JUST BE. YEAH. WE DID
SOMETHING AGAIN. WE HAVE GOT TO
MOVE THE NEEDLE. THE STATUS QUO
IS NOT ACCEPTABLE. AND I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU TO
MAKING SURE THAT THAT'S THAT
LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY THAT YOU
SEEK. RIGHT. AND I KNOW YOU AND
I WERE CO-CHAIRS AND YOUR YEAR
ONE, AND YOU'VE MOVED NOW INTO
SOME OF THE FUNDING AREAS. BUT
CONTINUE TO BE A CHAMPION IN
HUMAN SERVICES AS A LEADER. I
THINK THIS ALSO GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY RECRUIT
STRONG CANDIDATES FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT AND ENSURE THAT THIS
IS A PERSON THAT REPRESENTS THE
BIPOC COMMUNITY, THAT
UNDERSTANDS FOOD INSECURITY AND
IS NOT SIMPLY CHECKING THE BOX,
AS YOU SAID. SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO BEING THAT FORCE AND THAT
PARTNER WITH YOU AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD. ABSOLUTELY. AND
I'LL HAVE MY STAFF REACH OUT TO
YOURS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
EVERYTHING COVERED. GREAT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. OKAY,
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE
ORDER HERE, AND I SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO READY. WE'RE
GOING TO GO WITH FILE NUMBER
ONE. ASSEMBLY BILL 311. IF YOU
HAVE WITNESSES HERE WITH YOU
TODAY, WE'LL ASK THAT THEY COME
FORWARD TO THE CONFERENCE TABLE
AND WE'LL BE BRIEF. IF THE CHAIR
PREFERS THAT. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS WE'RE HERE TO PRESENT AB
311. AND IT'S A VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND SIMPLE,
REQUEST THAT WE'RE HAVING IN
THIS BILL. AND THAT'S THAT ALL
FOLKS, REGARDLESS OF
DOCUMENTATION STATUS, ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FOOD PROGRAMS UNDER
THE CALWORKS. PROGRAMS THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST, THIS IS
SOMETHING WE HAD FOUGHT FOR, AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
AND WITH US. WE HAVE ONE WITNESS
WHO WILL PRESENT. I'M NOT BEING
BRIEFED TO BE DISRESPECTFUL OF
THE COMMITTEE, BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF YOUR TIME, I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. WE'LL
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO PRESENT.
OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS JACKIE MENDELSON, AND I
AM A POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
NOURISH CALIFORNIA. WE ARE A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION THAT
COLLABORATES WITH COMMUNITY
PARTNERS TO BRING EQUITY TO OUR
STATE'S FOOD SAFETY NET THROUGH
POLICY ADVOCACY. AND A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 311, 64, OR
CLOSE TO 2 IN 3 UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL AGES ARE
LIVING IN OR NEAR POVERTY. AND
THIS IS ALMOST DOUBLE THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE AND XENOPHOBIC
EXCLUSIONS IN OUR SAFETY NET
MEAN THAT THE LOSS OF A JOB OR
AN EMERGENCY CAN QUICKLY DO HARM
AND PULL FAMILIES BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE. AND IN A STATE
THAT STRIVES TO BE A LEADER IN
IMMIGRANT INCLUSION AND EQUITY,
WE CANNOT LET IMMIGRATION STATUS
BE THE REASON THAT CALIFORNIANS
FALL THROUGH THE GAPS IN THE
SAFETY NET. A NEW STUDY BY THE
URBAN INSTITUTE FOUND THAT LOW
INCOME AMERICANS OFTEN PULL FROM
THEIR SAVINGS OR GO INTO DEBT TO
AFFORD THE RISING COST OF FOOD.
EDUARDO IS A COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER AND UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY MEMBER IN SAN
FERNANDO. LIVING THIS REALITY,
HE SHARED WITH US, DUE TO
INFLATION, MY SALARY FROM TWO
JOBS IS NOT ENOUGH TO COVER THE
BASIC EXPENSES OF MY HOUSEHOLD.
I FEEL DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
BECAUSE I AM NOT ELIGIBLE DUE TO
MY AGE. FOR THE NEW EXPANSION OF
THE CALFRESH PROGRAM SINCE MY
AGE DOES NOT REDUCE THE GREAT
NEED TO HAVE ACCESS TO DECENT
FOOD FOR MYSELF AND MY FAMILY.
THE STATE BUDGET PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE LAST WEEK PROPOSES A
HARMFUL DELAY TO THE EXPANSION
OF THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS AGES
55 AND OLDER AND OLDER
CALIFORNIANS THAT THOUGHT THEY
WOULD RECEIVE RELIEF THROUGH
FOOD BENEFITS STARTING IN 2020
5TH MAY NOW NEED TO WAIT ANOTHER
TWO YEARS OR MORE FOR THIS
CRITICAL SUPPORT. WHILE IT'S
WRITTEN AS A DELAY, UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ARE EXPERIENCING IT
AS A CUT. HUNGER IS HUNGER. NO
MATTER WHERE YOU WERE BORN. AND
THIS IS WHY AB 311 IS NOW MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER. I URGE YOU
TO VOTE AYE ON THIS BILL SO THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS, REGARDLESS OF
THEIR AGE OR IMMIGRATION STATUS,
CAN ACCESS THE FOOD THEY NEED.
NO EXCEPTIONS, NO EXCLUSIONS, NO
DELAYS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION,
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL 311, PLEASE COME
FORWARD WITH YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN, ANDREA
VISCA. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER, PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF THE
BILL AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS KATHY MOSS
WERE WITH BOTH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE AND CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS, BOTH
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CRAIG
PULSIPHER ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MARTHA
GUERRERO, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. HELLO.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
ALEJANDRO SOLIS, ON BEHALF OF
THE MEXICAN AMERICAN OPPORTUNITY
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, REBECCA
GONZALEZ, WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. JUSTIN BOWERS, CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS STRONGLY SUPPORT AND
THE NCCA NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE FAX AND THE ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PIECE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT. DO
WE HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? PLEASE COME FORWARD
OKAY. NOT SEEING ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION. WE'LL HEAR YOU
AT THE MICROPHONE. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING
THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS? CONCERNS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE, YES, MADAM CHAIR,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY. GREAT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'LL TAKE IT UP ONCE WE
GET A QUORUM. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARRILLO HAS BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY. I'M GOING TO GO OUT
OF LINE, AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO ITEM NUMBER
21, ASSEMBLY BILL 2929. ARE YOU
READY? ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO GIVE YOUR SPOT TO.
ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. ANY
WITNESSES WITH YOU HERE TODAY?
YES, I DO HAVE A WITNESS WITH ME
TODAY. I BELIEVE SHE IS HERE.
OKAY, COME FORWARD TO THE TABLE
WHEN THEY'RE READY. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS, FOR LETTING ME
GO FIRST. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
2929. I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN WITH
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS. I DO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ADVANCE FAMILY FUNDING
EFFORTS FOR YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE
BY REQUIRING SOCIAL WORKERS TO
INCLUDE ALREADY EXISTING
DOCUMENTATION FOR THESE EFFORTS
IN COURT REPORTS FOR REVIEW AND
HEARINGS. MANY CHILDREN IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM HAVE BEEN
REMOVED FROM THEIR HOMES DUE TO
ABUSE, NEGLECT, OR OTHER REASONS
BEYOND THEIR CONTROL. IN
CALIFORNIA, IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
THERE ARE NEARLY 45,000 CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE AND NEARLY 55% OF
THEM ARE LATINO. RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT CHILDREN WHO MAINTAIN
POSITIVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS WHILE IN
FOSTER CARE HAVE BETTER LONG
TERM OUTCOMES RELATED TO
HOUSING, MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH, AND EDUCATION. BY
CONNECTING CHILDREN WITH THEIR
FAMILIES, WE CAN PROVIDE THEM
WITH A SUPPORT AND STABLE
RELATIONSHIPS THEY NEED TO
THRIVE. THIS BILL WOULD HELP
MAKE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE
LIVES OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN. JOINING ME TODAY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTION IS JULIE
MCCORMICK WITH THE CHILDREN'S
LAW CENTER. THANK YOU, MISS
MCCORMICK. BEFORE YOU PRESENT,
WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. OKAY ALL RIGHT.
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM.
ALVARADO GIL, PRESENT. ALVARADO
GIL. PRESENT. OCHOA. BOGH BLAKE.
SPEER. PRESENT. BLAKE. SPEER.
PRESENT HURTADO. MENGIBAR. HERE
MENGIBAR. HERE. OKAY. WE NOW
HAVE A QUORUM, SO WE WILL BE
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. IT WILL GIVE
YOU TWO MINUTES TO PRESENT.
PLEASE START WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU. I DON'T BELIEVE WE'LL
NEED ALL THAT TIME. OKAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I'M JULIE MCCORMICK.
I'M A SENIOR POLICY ATTORNEY AT
THE CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE THE LARGEST
CHILDREN'S LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATION IN THE COUNTRY. WE
REPRESENT OVER 25,000 CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN LOS ANGELES,
SACRAMENTO, AND PLACER COUNTIES.
AND WE ARE PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR
OF AB 2929. DOCUMENTATION OF
FAMILY FINDING EFFORTS ARE
ESSENTIAL SO THAT ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM, ATTORNEYS AND JUDICIAL
OFFICERS WILL HAVE THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
FACILITATE MEANINGFUL AND
ONGOING FAMILIAL CONNECTIONS FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
ALREADY REQUIRED BY LAW AND
POLICY TO CONDUCT EXTENSIVE
FAMILY FINDING EFFORTS. ALL AB
2929 DOES IS ENSURE THAT THE
EFFORTS ALREADY BEING CONDUCTED
ARE PROVIDED TO THE COURT AND
COUNSEL. ADDITIONALLY IF COURTS
AND ATTORNEYS ARE PROVIDED WITH
THE INFORMATION UP FRONT IN
COURT REPORTS, THEY WON'T NEED
TO SET ADDITIONAL HEARINGS TO
OBTAIN THAT INFORMATION, WHICH
WILL INCREASE INCREASE COURT
EFFICIENCY TO ADDRESS FISCAL
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE GOVERNOR
LAST YEAR, THIS BILL WAS
TAILORED TO ONLY REQUIRE
DOCUMENTATION TO BE PROVIDED AT
REVIEW HEARINGS, AND ONLY WHEN
THOSE CHILDREN ARE NOT ALREADY
PLACED WITH A RELATIVE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN
PROMOTING FAMILIAL CONNECTIONS
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN. I'M ALSO HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH, WE WILL
ALLOW MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
COME FORWARD AND SHARE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. OKAY. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THAT
WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD? OKAY.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, ANY QUESTIONS
AROUND ASSEMBLY BILL 2929 FOR
OUR AUTHOR? OKAY. MOVED BY, VICE
SENATOR BLAKE SPHERE. OKAY WE'LL
HAVE YOU, SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR Þ. ACTUALLY, I WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE THE AUTHOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. I JUST
WANT TO ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU. GREAT. THANK YOU. OKAY, SO,
MOTION MADE BY SENATOR BLAKE'S
MOTION IS Dð. PASS IS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL I ECHO BOGUE.
BLAKE. SPEAR, I BLAKE. SPEAR. I
HURTADO. MENGIBAR. I THE VOTE IS
THREE EYES AND NO. NO. NOS AND
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. WE'LL
PUT THAT VOTE ON CALL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'LL READ
THIS PART I'LL READ THIS PART.
OKAY OKAY. YEAH. SO I'LL READ
THIS BACK. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE, WE ARE
GOING TO HEAR YOUR BILL, ITEM
NUMBER 17, ASSEMBLY BILL 3217.
AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK TO FILE
ORDER FOR OUR AUTHORS THAT ARE
HERE WAITING. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. CHAIRING
THE COMMITTEE MYSELF, IN THE
OTHER BUILDING. SO RUNNING BACK
AND FORTH. YES YES, THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME. AND IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU, SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
3217, A SIMPLE BILL THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT COUNTY WELFARE
AGENCIES ARE CONSISTENTLY USING
BEST PRACTICES FOR FAMILY
FINDING WHILE CONSIDERING
PLACEMENT OPTIONS FOR FOSTER
YOUTH AND THEIR CARE. I WANT TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING THEIR
EXCEPTIONAL, DETAIL AND THEIR
WORK WITH MY STAFF TO MAKING
SURE THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN. RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT WHEN A CHILD ENTERS
FOSTER CARE, PLACING THEM WITH A
RELATIVE OR OTHER LOVED ONE WHO
THEY ARE FAMILIAR WITH HAS LED
TO FAR BETTER OUTCOMES FOR THAT
CHILD AND EVERYBODY ELSE
INVOLVED. CHILDREN PLACED WITH
THEIR KIN HAVE FEWER PLACEMENT
DISRUPTIONS, SCHOOL CHANGES, AND
ARE LESS LIKELY TO RUN AWAY FROM
HOME. THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO
REPORT THAT THEY FEEL LOVED AND
SUPPORTED DURING THEIR TIME IN
FOSTER CARE. ACCORDING TO DATA
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
WELFARE INDICATORS PROJECT.
HOWEVER, THERE ARE COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE FALLING
BEHIND COMPARED TO THEIR PEERS
WHEN IT COMES TO PLACING A
FOSTER CHILD WITH THEIR KIN FOR
EXAMPLE, ONE MAJOR COUNTY HAS A
22% PLACEMENT RATE, WHICH IS
DRASTICALLY LOWER THAN THE STATE
AVERAGE OF 34% AND THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE OF 35.5. AB 3217 IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL THAT PUTS
FORTH TWO REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT COUNTIES ARE MEETING FAMILY
PLACEMENT EXPECTATIONS. FIRST,
IT WILL REQUIRE COUNTIES THAT
FALL BELOW THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE
TO CONSULT WITH THE STATEWIDE
CENTER FOR EXCELLENCE AND FAMILY
FINDING, ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT.
THE CENTER WAS ESTABLISHED IN
2022 AS A $150 MILLION
INVESTMENT TO SUPPORT FAMILY
FINDING EFFORTS ACROSS THE
STATE, BUT NOT ALL COUNTIES ARE
UTILIZING THIS RESOURCE. THIS
NEEDS TO CHANGE, PARTICULARLY
FOR COUNTIES THAT NEED THE
SUPPORT THE MOST. THE SECOND IS
IT WILL REQUIRE THOSE SAME
COUNTIES TO SIMPLY AGENDIZE THE
TOPIC. AT A COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HEARING. THIS WILL
PROVIDE THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY INTO WHAT EFFORTS
COUNTY WELFARE AGENCIES ARE
MAKING TO IMPROVE THEIR FAMILY
PLACEMENT RATES. THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PLACE
FOSTER YOUTH WITH LOVED ONES,
RATHER THAN STRANGERS, IN TIMES
OF GREAT INSTABILITY AND
DISTRESS. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH KDA TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS, AS EVIDENCED BY
TODAY'S COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS,
AND I'M COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TO DOING THAT WORK WITH THEM AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD TO
ADDRESS ANY REMAINING ISSUES.
JOINING ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
STATEMENTS IN SUPPORT ARE ED
HOWARD WITH THE CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY INSTITUTE AND SHADI
AJAYI, A LOCAL ORGANIZER, LEADER
AND FORMER STUDENT OF MINE. WHEN
I TAUGHT AT UCLA. WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU. YOU'LL EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT. OKAY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS SHADI AJAYI, A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH RAISED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. JUSTICE, A
JOBS ORGANIZER IN THE ESSENCE OF
BLACK GIRLHOOD PROJECT DIRECTOR
AND AN INCOMING FIRST YEAR LAW
STUDENT AT HOWARD UNIVERSITY
SCHOOL OF LAW. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE VITALITY OF THIS BILL. I
WAS FIVE YEARS OLD WHEN MY
SISTERS AND I WERE REMOVED FROM
OUR HOME. WE WERE MOVED TO FOUR
DIFFERENT STRANGERS HOMES WITHIN
ONE YEAR AND WAS TOLD IT WAS
BECAUSE THERE WERE NO HOMES FOR
US. LIVING WITH STRANGERS MADE
ME FEEL LIKE I DID NOT BELONG.
IF WE DID NOT FIT INTO THEIR
FAMILY STRUCTURES, CULTURES AND
TRADITIONS. WE WERE REMOVED FROM
THE HOME. I LIVED IN A CONSTANT
STATE OF HYPERVIGILANCE FROM
ABUSE, INSTABILITY, AND RACIAL
MICROAGGRESSIONS. EVENTUALLY, I
FELT RELIEVED AFTER FINALLY
BEING PLACED WITH MY AUNT IN A
HOME WHERE IT FELT LIKE MINE. IT
WAS A RELIEF BECAUSE I COULD
RELAX FOR THE REMAINING FIVE
YEARS OF FOSTER CARE. LIVING
WITH MY AUNT, I COULD LET MY
GUARD DOWN, WHICH HELPED ME
BEGIN HEALING FROM MY OWN TRAUMA
AND ALLOW ME TO FOCUS ON BEING A
KID WITH WHETHER I WAS SCHOOL,
FRIENDS, OR CULTURAL CONNECTION.
THE FAMILIARITY MADE ME FEEL
SAFE, SEEN, AND EMPOWERED. BEING
AROUND FAMILY HELPED ME DEVELOP
A SENSE OF HOPE AND BEING
CLOSER. REUNITED WITH MY MOTHER
AS A YOUNG BLACK WOMAN AND NOW
PROFESSIONAL, I KNOW FIRSTHAND
THE LONGING AND DISEMPOWERMENT
FOSTER CHILDREN FACE,
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN OF COLOR
AND WHAT TRAJECTORIES AND
EXPLOITATION FOSTER YOUTH
EXPERIENCED. I BECOME A CONSTANT
IN THEIR TRAUMATIZED LIFE. ALL
THIS BILL DOES IS ENSURE THAT
FOSTER CHILDREN IN THERE NEEDS
TO BE PLACED WITH FAMILIES, IS
NOT FORGOTTEN, BUT INSTEAD A
TOPIC OF ONGOING CONVERSATION AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL. RESPECTFULLY,
ON BEHALF OF THE FOSTER CHILDREN
WHO ARE LITERALLY CHILDREN OF
THE STATE IS NOT TOO MUCH TO
ASK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS. GOOD MORNING,
EDITOR HOWARD OR GOOD AFTERNOON.
EXCUSE ME, EDITOR HOWARD, SENIOR
COUNSEL OF THE CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY INSTITUTE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LAW. PLEASED TO SPONSOR THIS
BILL TO THE LITANY OF GREAT
OUTCOMES THAT COME FROM PLACING
OUR FOSTER CHILDREN WITH
FAMILIES. LET ME ADD THAT NEW
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT KINSHIP
CARE CAN IMPROVE ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES AND LONG TERM SUCCESS
FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE OUR FOSTER
CHILDREN. AND I'M SO PLEASED TO
HAVE SUCH A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
THOSE DATA. SITTING PROUDLY TO
MY LEFT, THE YOU'RE, BY THE WAY,
BEFORE I SAY ANYTHING, YOUR
AMENDMENTS, MADAM CHAIR, HAVE
MADE THIS A BETTER BILL, AND I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I THANK
YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR HARD AND
THOUGHTFUL WORK AND MAKING IT A
BETTER BILL. AS THE ANALYSIS
CORRECTLY POINTS OUT, ON PAGE
FIVE, NOT ONLY ARE THERE STATES
WHO ARE PERFORMING BELOW THE
AVERAGE OF ABOUT 35, WHICH IS
NOT A GREAT AVERAGE ALL BY
ITSELF, SOME OF THEM ARE
PERFORMING FAR, FAR LOWER,
MEANING THAT SOMETIMES ALMOST
80% OF THE TIME WE'RE NOT
PLACING OUR ABUSED AND NEGLECTED
CHILDREN WITH THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS. BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT SOME COUNTIES ARE DOING FAR
BETTER AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED. SO GIVEN THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS TO OUR FOSTER
CHILDREN, MAYBE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO FOR
THEM OTHER THAN RETURNING THEM
TO THEIR SAFELY TO THEIR
FAMILIES. GIVEN THAT WE KNOW WE
CAN DO BETTER, GIVEN THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS TO OUR
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA OF COVER
COLOR, SIMPLY HAVING A
CONVERSATION ONCE A YEAR AT THE
HIGHEST AND MOST ACCOUNTABLE
LEVEL ABOUT HOW WE CAN DO BETTER
IS REALLY NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK
FOR THESE CHILDREN WHO, AFTER
ALL, ARE OUR CHILDREN AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE THEIR SUPPORT. PLEASE COME
FORWARD WITH YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, STEPHANIE
ROBERSON, AUTHORIZED TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE BLACK YOUTH
LEADERSHIP PROJECT, THE NAACP
CHAPTER IN MERCED, AND ALSO THE
BLACK WOMEN ORGANIZED FOR
POLITICAL ACTION IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
T I JUSTIN BOWERS WITH CLEANER
FOR KIDS. ORG STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE ECO SUSTAINABLE PEEPS
AND THE NCCA ALSO SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL? PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND WE WILL HEAR YOUR TESTIMONY.
OKAY. WELCOME. TWO MINUTES.
WE'LL HEAR. THANK YOU, GOOD
AFTERNOON, AMANDA KIRCHNER, ON
BEHALF OF CDVA, WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. UNFORTUNATELY, THEY
DON'T COMPLETELY REVIEW. REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION, WE ABSOLUTELY
AGREE ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
PLACING OUR FOSTER YOUTH WITH
FAMILIES WHENEVER POSSIBLE. BUT
WE DO WANT TO KEEP IN MIND A
COUPLE OF THINGS. IN SOME OF OUR
SMALLER COUNTIES, WE DON'T
ALWAYS HAVE FAMILY AS OPTIONS.
AND SO THAT IS WHY SOMETIMES WE
DO SEE LOWER PERFORMANCES AND
FAMILY FINDING IN THOSE
COUNTIES, BECAUSE THERE SIMPLY
AREN'T RELATIVES AROUND THAT WE
CAN PLACE THEM WITH, OR TO DO SO
WOULD MEAN PLACING THEM ACROSS
COUNTY LINES. AND SO SOMETIMES
YOU HAVE TO BALANCE BETWEEN
KEEPING THEM IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT THEY KNOW VERSUS PLACING
THEM WITH A FAMILY MEMBER. SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE KEEP IN MIND WHEN WE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT BEST
PRACTICES. WE THINK, FOCUSING
THIS ON THE CENTER FOR
EXCELLENCE IS A GREAT STEP
FORWARD. WHAT WE'D LIKE TO SEE
IS MAKING SURE THAT AT CHS,
WHO'S IN CHARGE OF DETERMINING
WHO SORT OF FALLS BELOW THE 50%
MARK BASED ON DATA, WE DON'T
THINK OUR COUNTY SHOULD BE THE
ONES JUST TRYING TO
INDIVIDUALLY, INDEPENDENTLY
FIGURE OUT IF THEY ARE ABOVE OR
BELOW WHERE EVERYONE IS AT. WE'D
ALSO LIKE TO SEE THAT, IF IT'S
GOING TO BE REVIEWED BY THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, IT'S DONE
IN AN ALREADY EXISTING MANNER
THROUGH OUR SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT
PROCESSES OR SOME OF OUR OTHER,
SORT OF CASE PLAN, CASE C¢M THE
SELF IMPROVEMENT PLAN. THANK
YOU. SO, IMPORTANTLY, BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT IT TO BECOME A SECOND
TRACK THROUGH THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, WHAT WE DON'T WANT
TO SEE HAPPEN IS THINGS GET
BROUGHT UP AT BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS MEETINGS THAT EITHER
WE CAN INCORPORATE OR WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT'S SORT OF OUTSIDE
THE ALREADY EXISTING DSS
REGULATIONS FOR HOW WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE MEETING THOSE
GOALS. AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE. I THINK WE'RE
VERY CLOSE AND THAT WE CAN GET
TO MIDDLE GROUND, BUT JUST NOT
THERE YET. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE THEIR OPPOSITION
FOR THE BILL? PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE. OKAY.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY. SENATOR
BREAKSPEARE, THANK YOU. I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
BILL. I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR EVERY REASON THAT
MAKES INTUITIVE SENSE, THAT
PLACEMENTS WITHIN KINSHIP
RELATIONSHIPS WOULD BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL, ESPECIALLY IN
SMALLER OR RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY DATA THAT
INDICATES THAT COUNTY LINES
SOMEHOW STAYING WITHIN COUNTY
LINES IS SOMEHOW LEADS TO MORE
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES. SO I KNOW
THAT COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
ARE ORGANIZED AROUND COUNTY
LINES. AND SO IT CAN SEEM MORE
ADMINISTRATIVELY DIFFICULT TO
SUGGEST A KINSHIP PLACEMENT OVER
A COUNTY BOUNDARY. BUT I THINK
THE POINT OF THIS BILL, THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND GOOD BILL,
IS THAT KINSHIP PLACEMENTS ARE
JUST MORE SUCCESSFUL. SO WE
SHOULDN'T BE LIMITING OURSELVES
AROUND THESE ARTIFICIAL
BOUNDARIES OF WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT ENTITY HAPPENS TO BE.
SO, SO I, YOU KNOW, APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTARY FROM THE
OPPOSITION, BUT I ALSO JUST HOPE
THAT WE CAN DRIVE UP THE
PERCENTAGE, EVEN ABOVE A THIRD,
SO THAT THERE'S REALLY A
COMMITMENT TO TRY TO GET EVERY
SINGLE POSSIBLE KINSHIP
PLACEMENT, NO MATTER WHICH
COUNTY THEY HAPPEN TO LIVE IN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND WHEN IT COMES TIME, I'LL
MOVE THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. SENATOR TROBO QUESTION.
COMMENT HI. SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE, BILL NUMBER JUST TO
MAKE SURE I'M AT THE RIGHT ONE.
ITEM NUMBER 17, ASSEMBLY BILL
3217. IT'S A GREAT BILL. SO I
DID NOT HEAR THE COMMENTERS AND
I APOLOGIZE. I WAS PRESENTING A
BILL, ACROSS THE STREET, BUT WAS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION ABOUT THE,
AGE FOR SHARING A ROOM? I KNOW,
IS THIS A BILL? THIS IS A
DIFFERENT BILL. OKAY THEN IN
THAT CASE, I'M. I'M GOOD ON THIS
ONE. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
UNLESS YOU WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. NO. ALL RIGHT.
I'LL SAVE IT FOR MY CLOSE.
THERE. YOU GO, I, I HAVE TO GIVE
A LOT OF ACCOLADES FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRYAN BECAUSE HIM AND I
HAVE SEEN EACH OTHER IN THIS
COMMITTEE, NOW TWO YEARS. AND I
WOULD SAY OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
YOU'RE ONE OF THE STRONGEST
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH, AND AS I
GET TO SEE YOUR WORK MORE, YOU
HAVE BUILT QUITE A FAN BASE WITH
ME, AND SEEING YOUR BILLS COME
TO OUR COMMITTEE, NOT ONLY HAVE
YOU BEEN OPEN TO AMENDMENTS AND
WORKING ON ON THOSE CONNECTIONS,
BUT YOU'RE LETTING YOU KNOW A
SENATOR THAT REPRESENTS RURAL
COMMUNITIES COME OUT AND SAY,
HEY, I LOVE YOUR BILL, BUT IT'S
NOT GOING TO WORK IN MY SMALL
COMMUNITIES AND REALLY BEING
OPEN TO THAT. SO THANK YOU FOR
CARING FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND
YOUTH ALL OVER CALIFORNIA. NOT
ONLY IN YOUR DISTRICT, BUT MY
DISTRICT AND ALL OVER THE STATE.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. ALL RIGHT. SO WE HAVE
A MOTION. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE BEFORE WE MOVE TO THE
VOTE? YEAH, YOU KNOW, MY
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES KNOW THIS,
BUT, MY PARENTS HAD FOSTER CARE
FOR 26 YEARS. I WAS ONE OF NINE
ADOPTED CHILDREN. THERE WERE NO
FAMILY PLACEMENTS FOR ME. FOR
MANY CHILDREN ACROSS THE STATE,
THOUGH, THOSE KINSHIP PLACEMENTS
ARE KEY TO SUCCESS. I THINK THE
OPPOSITION HAS BROUGHT UP GREAT
POINTS. THEY'RE THE KIND OF
POINTS THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AGENDIZE AND TALK ABOUT EVERY
SINGLE YEAR ABOUT THE SUCCESS OR
LACK THEREOF IN THAT SUCCESS.
THANK YOU FOR THE AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE MADE THIS A STRONGER
BILL. ULTIMATELY, WHAT WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO DO IS WHAT'S BEST FOR
THE KIDS ACROSS OUR STATE WHO
NEED US AND WHO ARE COUNTING ON
US. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR BLAKE'S
ASSISTANT. WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATE COMMITTEE. ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE. ALVARADO GIL. AYE.
OTTOBOCK I AKABOGU AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
OKAY. WE HAVE THREE EYES. I'M
SORRY. OH, I'M SORRY, I DIDN'T
HAVE THAT ONE DOWN. I'M SORRY.
THAT IS Dð. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS, AS AMENDED. AS
AMENDED? YES. AND SO I'M GOING
TO RECALL THE VOTE JUST TO MAKE
SURE. YES. OKAY SORRY. ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE. ALVARADO GIL. AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH. OKOBOJI. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
HURTADO MENGIBAR. OKAY, WE HAVE
THE VOTE. IS THREE EYES AND NO
NOS. WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THAT
ON CALL FOR THE REST OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
TO YOUR WITNESSES AS WELL. ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. LOOKING INTO
THE AUDIENCE FOR AUTHORS, I SEE
SOMETHING. MEMBER REYES HAS BEEN
PATIENT, ASSEMBLYWOMAN, YOU'RE
ALSO GOING TO BE PRESENTING FOR
ITEM NUMBER 13 FOR WENDY
CARRILLO'S BILL, IS THAT
CORRECT? OKAY SO WE'LL HAVE YOU
START WITH ITEM NUMBER NINE,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1911. WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS. TODAY I PRESENT AB
1911 WHICH WILL IMPROVE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY, SPECIFICALLY WITH
REGARD TO COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS PERFORMED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. CURRENTLY THE
EXPERIENCE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
FILE COMPLAINTS AGAINST AN RQF
IS INADEQUATE AND DISCOURAGES
THEM FROM FILING. OFTENTIMES,
CDSS DETERMINATIONS. ON
COMPLAINTS ARE NOT COMMUNICATED
TO COMPLAINANTS, LEAVING THEM
WITHOUT THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO FOLLOW UP. COMPLAINT ON
COMPLAINTS, AND UNAWARE OF
WHETHER THEIR COMPLAINTS WILL BE
INVESTIGATED. THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT COMPLAINANTS RECEIVE A
WRITTEN NOTICE REGARDING
CRITICAL INFORMATION, INCLUDING
IF AN INVESTIGATION IS
WARRANTED. EXTENSIONS IN THE
INVESTIGATIVE INVESTIGATORY
PROCESS, AND BASIC INFORMATION
FOR FOLLOWING UP REGARDING THE
CASE. THE BILL ALSO IMPOSES A
DEADLINE OF 90 DAYS FOR
COMPLETING COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS AND REQUIRES
REQUIRES EXPEDITED
INVESTIGATIONS IF THEY INVOLVE A
THREAT OF IMMINENT DANGER OR
DEATH OR SERIOUS HARM. FINALLY,
THE BILL PROVIDES AN APPEALS
PROCESS FOR COMPLAINANTS WHO ARE
DISSATISFIED WITH THE RESULTS OF
CDSS IN INVESTIGATION AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTION. AB 1911 WILL
IMPROVE THE COMPLAINT PROCESS BY
IMPROVING CDSS COMMUNICATION
WITH COMPLAINANTS AND BY
IMPOSING CLEAR DEADLINES ON
COMPLAINT INVESTIGATIONS. HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ARE JACQUELINE FLORES, A
CONSUMER AND POLICY ADVOCATE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
FOR NURSING HOME REFORM, AND
BLANCA CASTRO, WITH THE STATE
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU BOTH FOR
BEING HERE, YOU'LL EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT. OKAY HELLO,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
JACQUELINE FLORES, AND I'M A
CONSUMER AND POLICY ADVOCATE
WITH CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM, ALSO KNOWN
AS CAÑADA FOR OVER 40 YEARS,
KANNER HAS ADVOCATED AND WORKED
TO IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM CARE SYSTEM FOR OLDER AND
DISABLED ADULTS. AB 1911 WILL
IMPROVE THE COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATION PROCESS FOR
RESIDENTS OF RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY,
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS RCF. UNDER
CURRENT LAW, THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING DIVISION, OR CLD IS
NOT REQUIRED TO SEND WRITTEN
NOTICES TO COMPLAINANTS ON
WHETHER THEIR COMPLAINT WILL BE
INVESTIGATED AND INFORMATION ON
WHAT TO EXPECT THROUGHOUT THE
INVESTIGATION PROCESS. NO
DEADLINES ON WHEN COMPLAINTS
SHOULD BE COMPLETED AND THERE IS
NO APPEALS PROCESS. LICENSES ARE
GIVEN FOUR LEVELS OF APPEAL WHEN
THEY ARE UNHAPPY WITH THE
COMPLAINT INVESTIGATION, WHILE
COMPLAINANTS GET NONE. RECENTLY,
I FILED A COMPLAINT FOR A
RESIDENT ABOUT AN UNLAWFUL
EVICTION. MY COMPLAINT CITED
LAWS AND REGULATIONS THAT WERE
CLEARLY VIOLATED, BUT I NEVER
RECEIVED A RESPONSE FROM CLD
ABOUT WHO WOULD BE INVESTIGATING
WHEN I COULD EXPECT THE
COMPLAINT TO BE INVESTIGATED, OR
IF MY COMPLAINT WOULD EVEN BE
INVESTIGATED. AFTER CONTACTING
THE REGIONAL OFFICE, I WAS
INFORMED CLD WOULD NOT BE
INVESTIGATING MY COMPLAINT
BECAUSE THE RESIDENT FILED ONE
HERSELF PREVIOUSLY AND CLD
DETERMINED IT UNSUBSTANTIATED.
MY COMPLAINT WAS NEVER
CONSIDERED AND CLD NEVER
COMMUNICATED WITH ME ABOUT THE
RESIDENT'S UNSUBSTANTIATED
COMPLAINT AND HOW IT RELATED TO
MY OWN. AFTER MANY EMAILS WITH
AN ASSISTANT PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR AND A REGIONAL
MANAGER, MY COMPLAINT WAS
REEVALUATED, INVESTIGATED AND
ULTIMATELY SUBSTANTIATED. BASIC
COMMUNICATION DEADLINES AND
OPTIONS TO APPEAL THE OUTCOME OF
AN INVESTIGATION ABOUT AN RCF
SHOULD BE THE DEFAULT. AB 1911
SEEKS TO IMPLEMENT GUIDELINES
THAT ARE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED IN
NURSING HOMES, AND WOULD PROVIDE
COMPLAINANTS GREATER ASSURANCE
THEIR COMPLAINT WILL BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY ON BEHALF OF CAÑADA
AND ADVOCATES ACROSS CALIFORNIA,
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR. I
VOTE ON AB 1911 TO IMPROVE
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE AND THE
DELIVERY OF CARE FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIRWOMAN
ALVARADO GIL AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE,
BLANCA CASTRO. AND I'M THE STATE
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN. WE
HAVE ABOUT 200,000 PEOPLE IN
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES THAT
ARE ALSO KNOWN AS ASSISTED
LIVING. THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES. THE
OMBUDSMAN ARE RESIDENT
ADVOCATES. THIS LAST YEAR WE HAD
ABOUT 10,340 VERIFIED COMPLAINTS
AND THE TOP FIVE COMPLAINTS IN
ASSISTED LIVING ARE PHYSICAL
ABUSE, GROSS NEGLECT, FINANCIAL
EXPLOITATION, DISCHARGE,
EVICTIONS AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
ABUSE. NOW, THIS BILL WILL
ACTUALLY REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING, A DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES, TO COLLABORATE MORE
QUICKLY, NOT ONLY WITH THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN, BUT ALSO
WITH THE COMPLAINANTS, BECAUSE
ANYBODY CAN FILE A COMPLAINT,
WHETHER YOU WORK THERE, WHETHER
YOU'RE A FAMILY MEMBER, ANY
MANDATED REPORTER AND IT DOES
CURRENTLY HAVE WE HAVE NO WAY OF
KNOWING WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT THAT WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN THEY INVESTIGATED
AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE GOING
TO TAKE ANY ENFORCEMENT ACTION
BECAUSE THE OMBUDSMAN IS NOT THE
ENFORCER. WE DO NOT ISSUE
PENALTIES, CIVIL PENALTIES, ETC.
SO WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR I
SUPPORT TODAY THIS IS ONE BILL
THAT IS GOING TO STRENGTHEN THE
RIGHTS OF OLDER ADULTS AND OLDER
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES. AND I
JUST WANT TO CLOSE WITH THIS.
JUST RECENTLY WE HAD A GENTLEMAN
WHO REACHED OUT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING, AND THEY
REFERRED THE CALL TO ME. HE HAS
THE INABILITY TO BECAUSE HE HAS
PARKINSON'S. HE WAS IN AN
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITY, OR SO
HE THOUGHT, AND HE CONTACTED US
AND WAS GOING TO GO TO THE FOOD
PANTRY, AND HE NEEDED
TRANSPORTATION. FIRST OF ALL, HE
SHOULDN'T GO TO A FOOD PANTRY
WHEN WE WENT OUT AND CHECKED ON
HIM, IT WAS AN UNLICENSED
FACILITY. THERE WERE SEVEN OTHER
PEOPLE IN THIS FACILITY. WE WERE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE AND CROSS
COMPLAIN TO NOT ONLY ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES, BUT TO
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
DIVISION OF CDSS. HOWEVER, WE
HAVE NOT HEARD WHAT THE OUTCOME
WAS OF OUR COMPLAINT. THIS IS
JUST ONE EXAMPLE. WE NEED TO
KNOW WHAT STEPS WERE TAKEN AND
HOW WE PREVENT THIS FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT, PLEASE
COME FORWARD WITH YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON. DANITA STROMGREN
, VOLUNTEER WITH CALIFORNIA AARP
ON BEHALF OF OUR 3.2 MILLION
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT. ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO BE HEARD. AND
WE'LL HAVE YOU JOIN US HERE AT
THE TABLE. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO PRESENT. DO YOU WANT TO GO
FIRST? GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, SELENA HORNBACK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION. WE REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED TO THIS BILL. WE
HAVE STRONG CONCERNS THAT THIS
BILL WOULD ADD ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES WITHOUT
ADDING ADEQUATE FUNDING. THIS
MULTI-STEP PROCESS WILL CAUSE
FURTHER DELAYS IN EXISTING
FUNCTIONS SUCH AS CURRENT
APPEALS THAT ARE UNRESOLVED
GOING BACK TO 2022. PROCESS
ADMINISTRATOR CERTIFICATES,
WHICH CURRENTLY TAKE SEVEN
MONTHS, AND MAINTAINING TIMELY
BACKGROUND CHECKS IN ADDITION TO
MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS TO
CONDUCT ANNUAL INSPECTIONS OF
ALL ARCHIVES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AMBER KING WITH LEADING AGE
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS OF CARE
SERVICES AND HOUSING FOR OLDER
ADULTS, SIMILAR TO THE ASSISTED
LIVING ASSOCIATION WHERE OUR
CONCERNED WITH THE CAPACITY OF
DSS TO CARRY OUT THE APPEALS
PROCESS IN THE BILL WITHOUT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OR RESOURCES
THAT THEY MIGHT NEED, THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALREADY FACING A
BACKLOG OF MANY OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE'VE ALREADY HEARD ABOUT,
AND WE'RE JUST CONCERNED THAT
THIS WILL ADD AN ADDITIONAL
LAYER ON TOP OF THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. YOU CAN STAY HERE.
WE MIGHT HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR
YOU. YES THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, ROXANNE GOULD,
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS. IT'S AN
ASSOCIATION OF SMALL RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY.
SIX BEDS OR FEWER. WE CONSIDER
THE ASSEMBLYWOMAN NGUYEN A ROCK
STAR AND AN ALLY IN SUPPORTING
THE MOST VULNERABLE AMONG US. WE
SHARE THE CONCERNS IN TERMS OF
COST AND WORKFORCE AVAILABILITY.
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION AND WE ARE
NOT OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. OKAY. WE WILL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS. SENATOR
BREAKSPEARE YES, THANK YOU. AND,
CHAIR, DO YOU MIND IF I ASK A
QUESTION OF ONE OF THE LEAD
WITNESSES? IS THAT OKAY? THAT'S
OKAY. COULD YOU JUST REPEAT THE
NUMBERS YOU SAID ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
WHO LIVE IN SKILLED NURSING AND
THEN LIVE IN ASSISTED LIVING?
YES, ABSOLUTELY. SO IN
CALIFORNIA, IN THE ASSISTED
LIVING, WE HAVE 200,000 BEDS,
APPROXIMATELY AND APPROXIMATELY
8000 LICENSED RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY, ALSO
KNOWN AS ASSISTED LIVING.
ANOTHER 1200 SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND ABOUT 100,000
BEDS THERE. AND THE NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS YOU SAID THAT WAS
RECEIVED VERY WIDE COMPLAINTS IN
2023, JUST WITH THE JUST WITH
THE ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES
OR IN ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITIES. 10,340 OKAY. THANK
YOU. WELL, I JUST I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. SO IN SOME WAYS I
THINK THAT THESE REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE ARE NOW IMPOSING ARE
THEY'RE COMMON SENSE THINGS LIKE
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT A COMPLAINT
WAS RECEIVED. I THINK SOME OF
THESE THINGS WE JUST ASSUME THAT
THEY'RE ALREADY HAPPENING AND
THAT AS AN INSTITUTION, WE WOULD
BE PROVIDING THE BASIC RESPECT
OF SAYING WE HAVE RECEIVED THIS
AND WE WILL BE INVESTIGATING IT,
AND THEN TO HAVE SOME TYPE OF A
PROCESS THAT COULD BE CAN BE
RELIED UPON. SO I THINK KEEPING
IN MIND HOW VULNERABLE THESE
POPULATIONS ARE, BOTH OF THEM,
THE SKILLED NURSING POPULATION,
WHICH DOES HAVE A PARTICULAR
COMPLAINT PROCESS, AND THEN THIS
OTHER ASSISTED LIVING
POPULATION, WHICH IS SOMETIMES
VERY CLOSE IN TERMS OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING IN THESE
FACILITIES OR THEY MOVE FROM ONE
TO THE NEXT, AND TO ME, IT MAKES
EVERY SENSE THAT WE WOULD NOT
HAVE A SYSTEM WHERE, THERE COULD
BE THE INSTITUTIONAL BETRAYAL,
ESSENTIALLY OF TRYING TO DEAL
WITH AN AGENCY AFTER FEELING
LIKE YOU'VE BEEN WRONGED AND
THEN NOT GETTING ANY RESPONSE.
SO YOU KNOW, I THINK KEEPING THE
BEST INTEREST OF PATIENTS IN
MIND, WE, OF COURSE, NEED THINGS
TO BE PROPERLY RESOURCED AND
CAPACITY TO BE THERE. AND THIS
MIGHT BE A STEP TOO. I MEAN, IF
THERE'S A RECOGNITION THAT WE
DON'T HAVE WHAT'S NEEDED. BUT,
YOU KNOW, TO ME, THIS SEEMS LIKE
A BASELINE THAT WE SHOULD
ALREADY BE DOING, AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WHEN SOMEBODY
FEELS THEY'VE BEEN WRONGED, THAT
WE'RE NOT COMPOUNDING THAT. AND
SOMETIMES THAT SECONDARY TRAUMA
CAN BE MORE THAN THE FIRST. WHEN
PEOPLE GO THROUGH THIS LONG
PROCESS AND THEY'RE UNABLE TO
GET ANY TYPE OF A RESOLUTION OR
EVEN KNOW THAT THEY'RE CARED
ABOUT. SO I THINK THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT
YOU BROUGHT IT FORWARD. AND OF
COURSE, WE NEED TO ALSO MAKE
SURE IT'S PROPERLY RESOURCED.
OKAY. AND WITH THAT I'LL MOVE IT
WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR BOK, THANK YOU.
AND I'M NOT SURE WHICH WHO WOULD
PROBABLY BE THE BEST TO ANSWER
THE FOLLOWING. BUT, HISTORICALLY
, THE ISSUES AND I'M REALLY
CONCERNED, THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE, THE BACKLOG THAT WE DO
HAVE CURRENTLY, THAT GOES BACK
TO 2022, THE SEVEN MONTH BACKLOG
, WITH THE TIMELY CHECKS ON ON
THE COMPLAINTS THAT WE HAVE
CURRENTLY. SO I AM I AM REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW DO WE PASS
ANOTHER ORDINANCE WHERE WE ARE
NOT CURRENTLY ENFORCING WHAT WE
ALREADY HAVE, AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE BIGGEST, EYE OPENING,
COMMENTS THAT I MAKE SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE. YOU KNOW, THIS IS MY
FOURTH YEAR IN THE LEGISLATURE,
BUT MANY OF OUR DEPARTMENTS, ARE
SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED. EVEN WHEN
WE HAD OUR SURPLUS, WE STILL
WERE UNDERFUNDED AND ON ON MANY
OF THESE, ON MANY OF THESE
AGENCIES. AND THE CONCERN THAT I
HAVE IS, ADDING ANOTHER LAYER OF
IT WHEN WE CAN'T EVEN FULFILL
WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE WITH THE
BACKLOG BACK TO 2022. THAT'S
RIDICULOUS, AND I'M JUST GOING
TO CURIOUS WHEN, WE'VE HAD,
BUDGET CONVERSATION IN THE PAST,
AS I SAID, I'M NOT SURE IF ANY
OF YOU WOULD HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS, BUT
WHAT HAS BEEN THE, THE ADVOCACY
TO INCREASE THE FUNDING IN THESE
PARTICULAR DEPARTMENTS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD? AND THE SECOND
PART OF IT IS, DO WE HAVE A
BUDGET, REQUEST TO ALLOW EXTRA
FUNDING FOR, FOR I KNOW THIS IS
FOR A DIFFERENT COMMITTEE, BUT
I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT THIS, I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE FUNDING
IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT, ANOTHER
REQUIREMENT. SENATORS, YOUR
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR OR ANY
WITNESS, IT'S OPEN BECAUSE I'M
NOT SURE WE DON'T HAVE THE
ACTUAL DEPARTMENT HERE TO ANSWER
, FOR THEM. SO I'M NOT SURE IF
ANYBODY WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS IF I MAY
BEGIN. AND THEN I'D LOVE FOR THE
WITNESSES TO ADD WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OPPOSITION THAT WE
HAVE RECEIVED, IT'S THESE
CONCERNS ARE LARGELY FOCUSED ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES CAPACITY TO ESTABLISH
AND MAINTAIN MULTI-STEP APPEALS
PROCESS WITHOUT CREATING FURTHER
BACKLOG. ALTHOUGH I ABSOLUTELY
DO APPRECIATE THE CONCERN AND
BELIEVE WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO FUND THESE
INVESTIGATIONS, WE MUST DEMAND
MORE OF THE DEPARTMENT OUT. EVEN
WITH THE CURRENT RESOURCES.
BASED ON ANECDOTES FROM THE,
BROUGHT FORWARD BY ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE KANNER, IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
STATUS QUO IS NOT WORKING. I
APPRECIATE IN THE ANALYSIS
PROVIDED BY THE COMMITTEE AT THE
VERY END UNDER COMMENTS. I THINK
IT SAYS IT ALL THAT HERE WE HAVE
A DEPARTMENT THAT DOESN'T EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE, AS THE SENATOR HAS
SAID, DOESN'T EVEN ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THEY RECEIVED A COMPLAINT.
SO THE FAMILY OR THE VERY, THE
VERY RESIDENT IS WONDERING, HAVE
THEY RECEIVED IT? SHOULD I BE
EXPECTING AN ANSWER? THEY
RECEIVED NOTHING. AND THEN ALSO
ON THE APPEALS PROCESS, THEY
AREN'T EVEN TOLD THAT THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO APPEAL AND WHAT
THE PROCESS WOULD BE. I THINK
THAT BY DEMANDING MORE OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE DEPARTMENT.
ABSOLUTELY. DURING OUR BUDGET
HEARINGS, AS WE KNOW, CAN COME
FORWARD AND SAY WE NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING, BUT TO LEAVE
THE STATUS QUO AS IT IS, I THINK
IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM, SO IN YOUR
HOPE WITH THIS PARTICULAR BILL
WOULD BE THAT BY PASSING THIS
BILL THAT THEY WILL, BASICALLY
REFORMAT THE PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD TO HOW TO FILE THE
COMPLAINTS AND HOW TO ADDRESS
THE COMPLAINTS AS THEY MOVE
FORWARD. IT'S BASICALLY,
UPDATING THEIR, THEIR, THEIR
PROCESS IS THAT AND AS WAS
MENTIONED, EACH OF THOSE
RESIDENTS DESERVES TO BE TREATED
WITH DIGNITY. IF A COMPLAINT HAS
BEEN RECEIVED, THAT COMPLAINT
SHOULD BE ACKNOWLEDGED,
ACKNOWLEDGED. AND THAT'S THE
VERY FIRST STEP THAT THE FACT
THAT AND IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE.
AND WHEN I READ ABOUT THE ISSUE,
TO KNOW THAT YOU CAN COMPLAIN
ABOUT SOMETHING AND THERE'S
CRICKETS, NOBODY IS
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THEY HAVE
RECEIVED YOUR COMPLAINT. YOU
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE WORKING ON
IT, WE DID INCLUDE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ABOUT CRITICAL OR OR
, IF, IF DEATH, POSSIBILITY OF
DEATH, THOSE HAVE TO BE WORKED
ON IMMEDIATELY. THEY CAN'T BE
PUT. WE CAN'T BE TOLD THERE'S
SUCH A BACKLOG. WE CAN'T EVEN
TAKE CARE OF THOSE NØ THOSE HAVE
TO GO TO THE VERY TOP. THEY HAVE
TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED. THOSE HAVE
TO BE WORKED ON IMMEDIATELY. AND
ONE FINAL COMMENT, CHAIR, IF I
MAY, YOU KNOW, THIS WOULD BE A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF HOW WE COULD
ACTUALLY USE AI TO GENERATE
THOSE AUTOMATIC RESPONSES WHEN
YOU KNOW SOMETHING IS RECEIVED
AND HAVE, YOU KNOW, NOTE ON
THERE, YOU KNOW, IF IT'S A
CRITICAL LIFE AND DEATH. AND SO
FORTH, I THINK THIS WOULD BE A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF WHERE WE COULD
ACTUALLY UTILIZE THOSE, YOU
KNOW, NEW RESOURCES ADDRESSING
WITH THE AI. AND WE WOULD
IMAGINE THAT BECAUSE IT'S
AVAILABLE THAT THAT WOULD BE
DONE. UNFORTUNATELY IT ISN'T.
BUT I DO WANT TO ADD, SENATORS
THAT CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT OVERSEES
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES DOES
EMPLOY A NOTIFICATION WHEN WE DO
SUBMIT ANY COMPLAINANT
IMMEDIATELY, TEN DAYS OR SOONER,
THERE'S A NOTICE, IT'S A LETTER
SAYING HERE WE'RE GOING TO
INVESTIGATE. THIS IS THE NAME OF
THE ANALYST WHO'S INVESTIGATING
YOUR COMPLAINT. AND WE WILL
RESPOND BACK WITH OUR FINDINGS.
THAT'S ALL WE'RE ASKING. AND IN
THIS BILL IT SAYS THAT ON OR
AFTER JULY 1ST, 2025, THE
DEPARTMENT WILL DO THIS. SO
WE'RE NOT SAYING GO BACK TO ALL
OF THE COMPLAINTS THAT YOU HAVE
AS A BACKLOG. WE'RE SAYING
STARTING FROM 2025 JULY 1ST,
LET'S IMPLEMENT THIS PROCESS. I
WOULD ALSO I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ADD WE DID ALSO INCLUDE A
GRADUATED TIMELINE TO GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
MORE TIME TO INVESTIGATE THESE
COMPLAINTS, AS WELL, AND ALSO
THIS BILL IS, IS ONLY ASKING THE
DEPARTMENT TO JUST DO WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
ALREADY, WHICH IS INVESTIGATING
THE COMPLAINTS AND HAVING A
BACKLOG. SO FAR, SOME PEOPLE
ACTUALLY PASS AWAY BEFORE THEIR
COMPLAINTS EVEN GET
INVESTIGATED, AND ONCE AGAIN,
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE PROVIDERS GET FOUR
LEVELS OF APPEAL AND
COMPLAINANTS DON'T HAVE ANY. AND
AS BLANCA ALSO ADDED THAT IN
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES, THEY
DO ALSO HAVE AN APPEALS PROCESS.
AND THIS BILL IS MODELED AFTER
AFTER THE COMPLAINT,
INVESTIGATIONS AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES, AND WITHIN
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES,
THERE'S ONLY ABOUT 24 INFORMAL
CONFERENCES PER YEAR. SO THE
APPEALS PROCESS IS NOT IS NOT
UTILIZED AS AS MUCH AS WE
ANTICIPATE IT TO BE, AT LEAST IN
NURSING HOMES. AND THIS
INFORMATION WAS GIVEN BY THE
PUBLIC, PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST AS WELL. THANK YOU. GET
ANSWERS TO YOUR QUESTIONS,
SENATOR. YES YES. THANK YOU.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO REALLY, FOR
ME, THIS IS A BILL ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY, SOMETHING THAT
OUR STATE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
ALREADY BE DOING. AS YOU SAID,
THE MINIMUM ACKNOWLEDGED
RECEIPT, AND I JUST I CANNOT
FATHOM SOMEBODY WAITING YEARS TO
EVEN KNOW THAT THEIR COMPLAINT
HAS BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED, AND SO
I'M, I'M, I'M SADDENED THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE A LEGISLATIVE ACT
IN ORDER TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE
STATE AGENCIES. SO WE HAVE TO DO
BETTER, AND I IF IT MEANS THAT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE AS
LEGISLATORS, WAS TO PUT PRESSURE
ON OUR STATE AGENCIES TO DO
BETTER. WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT. BUT WE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO.
RIGHT. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I THINK
WE HAVE A MOTION. I HEARD A
MOTION FROM SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
SO, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
BEFORE WE DO THE ROLL CALL? I DO
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE SITTING
AT THE TABLE. THESE ARE. THESE
ARE OUR CHAMPIONS. THEY ARE THE
ONES WHO ARE TAKING CARE OF
THOSE WHO ARE IN NEED. SO THERE
MAY BE OBJECTION TO LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL, BUT I KNOW THAT THE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. I
KNOW SOMETHING THAT WE ALL GET
TO WORK ON TOGETHER. ALL RIGHT.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. RIGHT. SO I HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR BLAKESLEE, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. ALVARADO,
GILL. Ã ALVARADO. GILL Ã
OCHOA. BOGH I AKABOGU I BLAKE.
SPEAR I BLAKE. SPEAR I HURTADO.
MENGIBAR HI. HURTADO I OKAY.
MENGIBAR I FOR YES. MENGIBAR I
YES. MENGIBAR I THANK YOU SO,
FOR, EYES OR FOR NOES ZERO. WE
WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU. OKAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, ARE YOU READY TO PRESENT
ON, ITEM NUMBER 13 OR DO YOU
NEED TIME? I AM NO, I AM OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. WITNESSES COMING UP.
ALL RIGHT, SO WE. HELLO SO WE'LL
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER 13, ASSEMBLY
BILL 2383 TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY. THANK
YOU. GOOD TO SEE YOU. GOOD TO
SEE YOU TOO. ALL RIGHT. WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO,
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2383,
WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
WITH WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ARE INFORMED ABOUT
AVAILABLE PROGRAMS THAT THEY
WILL LIKELY WOULD QUALIFY FOR,
AND TO ALLOW THEM TO ALLOW THEIR
CHILD TO RECEIVE MEDI-CAL
WITHOUT THEIR PARENTS INCOME
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION.
CHILDREN WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ARE CHILDREN WITH
AN ACUTE OR CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITION THAT REQUIRE THINGS
LIKE THERAPEUTIC INTERVENTION
AND SKILLED NURSING CARE DURING
ALL OR PART OF THE DAY. AMONG
THESE CONDITIONS ARE SEVERE LUNG
DISEASES REQUIRING OXYGEN OR
VENTILATOR, SPINA BIFIDA, HEART
DISEASE, NEUROMUSCULAR DISEASE,
CYSTIC FIBROSIS, AND SEIZURE
DISORDERS. SUPPORT FOR MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES IS CRITICAL TO
MAXIMIZING QUALITY OF LIFE AND
ALLOWING FAMILIES TO BE WHOLE.
FAMILIES MAY HAVE A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME WITH THEIR CHILD,
OR MAY STRUGGLE TO ENSURE THEIR
CHILD CAN PARTICIPATE AT SCHOOL
AND IN AGE APPROPRIATE
ACTIVITIES. DUE TO FINANCIAL
STRAINS AND THE COMPLEXITIES OF
NAVIGATING CARE. IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT FOR MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES THAT ARE OVER THE
THRESHOLD TO RECEIVE MEDI-CAL TO
NAVIGATE IT ALL STATE WAIVER
PROGRAMS ALLOW FAMILIES THAT
NORMALLY WOULDN'T QUALIFY FOR
MEDI-CAL TO RECEIVE TO RECEIVE
IT FOR THEIR CHILD, HELPING TO
COVER THE COSTS OF CARE AND
OFFER CARE COORDINATION SUPPORT.
THIS GIVES FAMILIES MORE TIME TO
BE WITH THEIR CHILD, BUT THERE
IS AN INFORMATION GAP THAT
LEAVES THESE WAIVER PROGRAMS
THAT COULD BE COULD DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVE A FAMILY'S SITUATION
UNDER UTILIZED. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A TRAINING FOR HOSPITAL
AND REGIONAL CENTER STAFF TO
ENSURE THEY HAVE UP TO DATE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT WAIVER
PROGRAMS ARE OFFERED SO THEY CAN
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
FAMILIES THAT WOULD LIKELY
QUALIFY. THIS TRAINING WOULD BE
CREATED WITH THE WORK OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES, AS WELL
AS WITH STAKEHOLDER INPUT HERE
TO TALK MORE ABOUT THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL AND ANSWER QUESTIONS,
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER,
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY AT THE
ARC OF CALIFORNIA. WELCOME. YOU
KNOW, THE DRILL WILL GIVE YOU
TWO MINUTES AND WE MIGHT HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOU
AFTERWARDS. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS, JIM FRAZIER WITH
THE ARC OF CALIFORNIA AND UNITED
CEREBRAL PALSY, A CALIFORNIA.
JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU AND THE
STAFF FOR MAKING A WONDERFUL
BILL ANALYSIS AND ACTUALLY DOING
THE RESEARCH AND FINDING, SOME
INFORMATION FOR MYSELF ALSO, HOW
TO HOW TO WORK THROUGH THAT
PROCESS WITH STAFF TURNOVERS
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY AND THE
BIRTHING CENTERS AND THE
REGIONAL CENTERS. THERE'S NO
PROCESS IN PLACE TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE OR A
PROTOCOL TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
THESE WAIVERS AS, DERBY'S
LEGACY, AS MENTIONED IN THE BILL
ANALYSIS, UNFORTUNATELY, CINDY
ANN COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY.
DERBY'S MOTHER, TO SHARE WITH
YOU THE ARDUOUS PROCESS THAT SHE
WENT THROUGH TO TRY TO GET
SERVICES, THIS BILL WILL CREATE
THE TRAINING NECESSARY TO BE
ABLE TO OFFER OP, OPT IN TO
THESE WAIVER PROGRAMS, TO CREATE
ALL OF THE COMPASSIONATE CARE
THAT THESE FAMILIES DESERVE WITH
THE MEDICALLY FRAGILE, THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED, AND
WHAT THEY WOULD CALL MEDICALLY,
INCAPABLE BEALL. AND SO I JUST
AM HERE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY IN FRONT OF YOU. AND I
WANT TO THANK MY GOOD FRIEND,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO AND HER
TEAM FOR HELPING US BRING THIS
FORWARD TO YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WANT TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL 2383,
PLEASE COME FORWARD. HI, JUSTIN
BOWERS, CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS ORG
STRONGLY SUPPORTS. IN ADDITION,
THE NORTH COUNTY OR NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PIECE AND THE
NCCA ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. OKAY. DO
WE HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE
HEARD TODAY? OKAY. SEEING NONE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE. WE'LL
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OKAY. I DON'T SEE ANY.
ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? WELL, ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO, SHE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
HER OFFICE AS WELL AS THE
SPONSOR OF THE ARC OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
GREAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION MOVED BY SENATOR
OCHOA? ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
HEALTH COMMITTEE. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. Ã.
OCHOA. BOGH AKABOGU. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. Ã. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
HURTADO. MENJIVAR. MENGIBAR AYE.
ALL RIGHT. EYES ARE FOUR ZERO
NOES. WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON
CALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, TAKE A LITTLE
BIT OF A STRETCH BREAK RIGHT
NOW. LET'S SEE WHERE WE ARE AT.
ALL RIGHT I SEE MEMBER ALANIZ IS
HERE. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. ARE YOU
READY FOR ASSEMBLY BILL 1817 TO
BE PRESENTED? WONDERFUL. OKAY
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER 11. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS. OKAY OKAY. ANY WITNESSES
WITH YOU HERE TODAY? NO CHAIR.
NO WORRIES. KEEPING THE SAMPLE,
I HAVE TO GIVE INSTRUCTION FOR
PEOPLE TO PUT THEIR CHAIRS BACK
IN ORDER. YEAH I THOUGHT MAYBE
THEY'D RUN BACK IN. RIGHT?
RIGHT. OKAY, GREAT. ALL RIGHT,
WELL, GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. FIRST AND FOREMOST,
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR, STAFF
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ANALYZING AND WORKING ON THIS
CRUCIAL BILL. SO THANK YOU GUYS
VERY MUCH. AB 1817 WOULD CREATE
TWO NEW GOALS TO END AND PREVENT
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS UNDER THE
HOMELESS YOUTH ACT OF 2018.
UNDER THIS ACT, THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED FOUR GOALS TO TRACK
AND PREVENT HOMELESSNESS AMONG
THOSE AGES 12 TO 24 AND THE
CURRENT GOALS ARE ONE. DECREASE
THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS YOUTH
TWO. DECREASE HOMELESSNESS
CAUSED BY SEPARATION FROM FAMILY
OR A LEGAL GUARDIAN THREE
DECREASE THE DURATION AND
FREQUENCY OF HOMELESS
EXPERIENCES AND NUMBER FOUR
EXPEDITE ACCESS TO SOCIAL
SERVICES, WELFARE SERVICES,
REGIONAL CENTERS AND MENTAL
HEALTH CARE. AB 1817 WOULD ADD
TWO ADDITIONAL GOALS TO THIS
LIST ONE. DECREASE THE NUMBER OF
HOMELESS YOUTH EXPERIENCING FOOD
INSECURITY AND TWO INCREASE
ACCESS TO EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND ECONOMIC
STABILITY. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A MORE COMPREHENSIVE LIST
OF GOALS FOR BATTLING THIS
ONGOING HOUSELESS, ONGOING
HOUSING CRISIS. BETWEEN 2020 AND
2022, THE PERCENTAGE OF ADULTS
AGES 18 TO 24 EXPERIENCING FOOD
INSECURITY ROSE FROM 36.7% TO
47.7. HOMELESSNESS CAN INCREASE
THE LIKELIHOOD OF CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS, MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES, SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND MORE
. SENATORS, THIS LEGISLATION
WILL HELP THE COMMISSION VIEW
HOMELESSNESS WITH A BROADER,
MORE EXCLUSIVE LENS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. WELCOME. KIM LEWIS,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH, ONE OF THE
CO-SPONSORS OF SB 918, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OKAY JUSTIN BOWERS WITH CLEAN
AIR FOR KIDS. ORG STRONGLY
SUPPORTS. IN ADDITION NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND THE
NCCA ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. DO
WE HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF TODAY'S BILL?
OKAY. SEEING NONE, MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE
. ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION
SO MOVED BY SENATOR OCHOA BOGH
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLE.
MOTION IS PASSED TO HOUSING
COMMITTEE. ALVARADO GIL, I
ALVARADO. GIL I OCHOA. BOGUE I
AKABOGU I BLAKE. SPEER I BLAKE.
SPEER I HURTADO. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I HAVE EYES OR FOUR
NOES. ZERO. WE WILL LEAVE THAT
BILL ON CALL. THANK YOU CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. MEMBER RIVAS, WHILE
YOU ARE GETTING SITUATED, I'M
GOING TO MOVE US TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE EIGHT BILLS ON
THE PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE. ITEM NUMBER THREE,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1876, FILE ITEM
FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL 1808. FILE
FILE. ITEM EIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL
2866. FILE ITEM TEN. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2207. FILE ITEM 12.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2343. FILE ITEM
15. ASSEMBLY BILL 2664. FILE
ITEM 16. ASSEMBLY BILL 2906 AND
FILE ITEM 20. ASSEMBLY BILL
2832. ANY MEMBERS WISH TO REMOVE
BILLS FROM CONSENT I SEE NONE.
DO I HAVE A MOTION MOVED BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR, ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
HURTADO MENGIBAR. AYE. MENGIBAR.
AYE OKAY. AYES. FOUR NOES. ZERO.
WE WILL LEAVE THE CONSENT ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO ITEM NUMBER 11,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1947, THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. I WANT TO START BY
THANKING YOU AND YOUR TEAM FOR
WORKING WITH ME AND MY STAFF ON
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS TO
THIS BILL. AB 1947 WOULD EXPAND
THE NUMBER OF STAFF TRAINING
DAYS FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS AND ALLOCATE
ONE OF THOSE DAYS FOR DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNER TRAINING. IN
2020, THE GOVERNOR RELEASED THE
MASTER PLAN, INTENDED TO
TRANSFORM THE STATE'S APPROACH
TO EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
THE MASTER PLAN PROVIDES A
ROADMAP TO ADDRESS RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC INEQUITIES, AND CALLS
FOR LEGISLATION TO REQUIRE,
DEVELOP MENTAL ASSESSMENTS, BOTH
IN ENGLISH AND IN CHILDREN'S
HOME LANGUAGES, AMONG OTHER
THINGS. IN 2021, CALIFORNIA
SIGNED INTO LAW AB 1363, WHICH
TOOK THE FIRST STEP OF
IMPLEMENTING THE MASTER PLAN BY
REQUIRING THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO DEVELOP A
STANDARDIZED PROCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM PROVIDERS TO IDENTIFY
DLS AS AB 1947 BUILDS ON THE
PROGRESS MADE IN AB 1363, IN
ACHIEVING THE GOALS OF THE
MASTER PLAN TO SUPPORT OUR DLS
BY HELPING OUR EDUCATORS CATER
TO THE LEARNING NEEDS OF OUR
CHILDREN. TODAY I HAVE WITH ME
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY, ANI
CAROLYN CROLLA, DIRECTOR OF DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNER PROGRAMS AT
EARLY AGE CALIFORNIA, AND
CHRISTINA SALAZAR, LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER. THANK YOU BOTH FOR
BEING HERE. YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT. THANK YOU.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON, ESTEEMED
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. LET'S JUST CLOSE.
OKAY FIRST, WE'D LIKE TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HER
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP IN THE
SPACE OF SUPPORTING DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS, AS SHE
MENTIONED, TAKING THE FIRST STEP
WITH AB 1363 TO CREATE THIS
FIRST IN THE NATION, SUPPORTS
FOR DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS
PROCESS FOR IDENTIFICATION AND
DATA COLLECTION. THÀNH, AND ALSO
THANK YOU TO THE STAFF FOR THEIR
INCREDIBLE ANALYSIS ON THE BILL,
WHICH REALLY POINTS TO THE NEED
AND THE CLEARLY CLEAR
ARTICULATION AS TO WHY WE NEED
THIS BILL, WHICH IS THAT
CONSISTENTLY, RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT MULTILINGUALISM REAPS
NUMEROUS BENEFITS NOT ONLY FOR
THE CHILDREN, BUT ALSO FOR
LARGER SOCIETY Kò, AND FOR THE
STATE AND THEN ALSO THAT STAFF
WHO TEACH AND SUPPORT OUR YOUNG
DLS REALLY NEED ACCESS TO
TRAINING ABOUT HOW TO BEST
SUPPORT THEIR CULTURAL AND
LINGUISTIC NEEDS, AS WELL AS
WELL AS HOW TO EFFECTIVELY
ENGAGE FAMILIES TO SUPPORT THEIR
CHILDREN'S LEARNING AT HOME. AND
SO WE SIMPLY CANNOT IGNORE THE
NEED FOR OUR STATE, WHICH IS THE
LARGEST, THE STATE WITH THE
LARGEST PERCENTAGE OF DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS IN THE NATION,
TO EFFECTIVELY SUPPORT THEIR
NEEDS. SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHRISTINA SALAZAR.
WITH CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER,
WE'RE A PROUD CO-SPONSOR. I
WOULD SECOND EVERYTHING THAT OUR
EARLY PARTNERS STATED. AND JUST
WANT TO ADD THAT AB 1947 WOULD
NOT ONLY BENEFIT EDUCATORS, BUT
ULTIMATELY CREATES A MORE
SUPPORTIVE AND WELL-ROUNDED
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
CHILDREN, BY EMPOWERING OUR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS WITH
THE NECESSARY SKILLS AND
KNOWLEDGE, AB 1947 EFFECTIVELY,
SUPPORTS THEM WITH EDUCATIONAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS FOR ALL
CHILDREN, INCLUDING DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. LASTLY AS A
MOM OF A THREE YEAR OLD AND AN
ALMOST TWO YEAR OLD, I
APPRECIATE THE LATEST AMENDMENTS
ON THE 30 DAY NOTICE. SO THANK
YOU AND WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU. NICOLE WATERMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HI. CAROL GONZALEZ FROM
BEHALF OF HISPANAS ORGANIZED FOR
POLITICAL EQUALITY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. YOU GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. PAMELA
GIBBS, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO BURY SAN
CARLOS, CALIFORNIA, AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MCKENZIE
RICHARDSON, THRIVING FAMILIES,
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON. CARLOS ROJAS
REPRESENTING THE KERN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS OFFICE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ON
IOAKIMIDIS, ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WRITE ANY LEAD WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION HERE TODAY. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. OKAY. SEEING NONE,
WE WILL MOVE THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OKAY. OKAY. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR BLAKE SPARE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE TODAY?
THANK YOU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. GREAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR BLAKE SPARE
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL. Ã. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. AQUEBOGUE AYE. AKABOGU.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE HURTADO. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE YEAH. FOUR EYES
AND ZERO NOES. WE WILL LEAVE
THAT BILL ON CALL. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH. THANKS FOR BEING HERE. ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. I SAU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALLACE. COME IN, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE NUMBER 14,
ASSEMBLY BILL 2410. THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES WITH YOU TODAY? I DO
NOT, OKAY. WE WILL MOVE FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
2410, WHICH ADDRESSES SENIOR
NUTRITION. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING CURRENTLY
HAS TWO MEAL PROGRAMS FOR
SENIORS WHO FACE FOOD INSECURITY
THE CONGREGATE MEALS PROGRAM AND
THE HOME DELIVERED NUTRITION
PROGRAM. DURING COVID, MANY
CITIES PROVIDED MEALS TO GO
RATHER THAN CONGREGATE TO
PROTECT SENIORS. WITH THIS
CHANGE, THEY REPORTED SERVING
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE SENIORS. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE LESSONS
FROM THE PANDEMIC TO IMPROVE OUR
GOVERNMENT SERVICES. THIS BILL
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE TO
GO OPTION FOR SENIORS WHO ARE
FOOD INSECURE, AS AN OPTION
WITHIN THE CONGREGATE MEALS
PROGRAM, MANY SENIORS ARE
REQUIRED TO TAKE PRESCRIPTIONS
DURING MEAL TIMES, AND THESE
SCHEDULES CAN BE DIFFERENT FROM
CONGREGATE MEAL SCHEDULES. THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THE BILL ANALYSIS. I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE FISCAL IMPACT
REFERENCED IN THE ANALYSIS. WHEN
MY BILL FIRST WENT TO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE, COST
ESTIMATES WERE BASED ON CREATING
AN ENTIRELY NEW FOOD PROGRAM AND
WAS TAGGED WITH A SUBSTANTIAL
GENERAL FUND PRICE TAG. IT WAS
NEVER OUR INTENT TO CREATE A NEW
PROGRAM, BUT RATHER OUR GOAL IS
SIMPLY TO PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
WITHIN THE CONGREGATE MEALS
PROGRAM. THE BILL IN FRONT OF
YOU DOES JUST THAT. I SHOULD ADD
NO ADDITIONAL COST TO THE
CONGREGATE MEALS PROGRAM. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
. ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME FORWARD TO
THE MICROPHONE. JUSTIN BOWERS
WITH CLEAN AIR FOR KIDS. ORG
STRONGLY SUPPORTS. IN ADDITION,
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
FACTS ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS
AND THE NC CCA ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAROLINE GRINDER,
ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. DARBY KERNAN, ON
BEHALF OF LEADINGAGE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD
TODAY? OKAY. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. OKAY. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL MOVE THE CONVERSATION BACK
TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS.
SENATOR. BLAKESPEAR. YES THANK
YOU. I PLAN TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL, BUT I JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS MY CONCERN ABOUT IF WE
ARE IF WE SEE AN EFFORT TO
ELIMINATE THE IN-PERSON EATING
COMPLETELY, BECAUSE I THINK WE
LEARNED MANY LESSONS FROM THE
PANDEMIC. ONE OF THEM WAS
LONELINESS IS AN EPIDEMIC, AND
IT'S GETTING WORSE, ESPECIALLY
AMONG SENIORS. SO HAVING I
VISITED SOME OF THESE MEAL
OPTIONS WHERE PEOPLE ARE EATING
TOGETHER, THEY'RE BREAKING
BREAD, THEY'RE SHARING THEIR
STORIES OF THEIR LIVES, THEY'RE
CREATING COMMUNITY. AND SO THERE
ARE A LOT OF ANCILLARY BENEFITS
OF PROVIDING MEALS TOGETHER. AND
ALSO, SOME SENIORS DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO REHEAT FOOD, AND
THEY MIGHT NOT HAVE OVENS OR
MICROWAVES IN THEIR PLACES. SO I
JUST WANT TO I SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE MORE OPTIONS IS BETTER,
BUT I WANT TO ALSO JUST MAKE
SURE TO STATE ON THE RECORD THAT
I HOPE WE THAT THERE ISN'T AN
EFFORT TO MOVE TOWARD ONLY A
PICKUP OR DELIVERY OPTION AND
NOT A CONGREGATE EATING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR NOTE
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. ALL
RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
JUST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. DO WE HAVE A MOTION? ALL
RIGHT. MOVED BY SENATOR MENGIBAR
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO, GIL Ã. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. AQUEBOGUE. AQUEBOGUE. AYE
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. HURTADO MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR.
AYE. WE HAVE. THE EYES ARE FOUR
ZERO NOES. WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL
ON. CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE TWO MORE BILLS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE HEARD
TODAY. ITEM NUMBER 18.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON, I SEE
THAT YOU'RE HERE. THANK YOU, WE
WILL HEAR NOW, ASSEMBLY BILL
2774 WHEN YOU'RE READY AND WE'LL
INVITE YOUR WITNESSES TO COME
FORWARD AND TAKE A SEAT. THANK
YOU SO VERY, VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AB
2774 ESTABLISHES THE CHILD CARE
FOR WORKING FAMILIES TASK FORCE
AND REQUIRES THAT THE TASK FORCE
SUBMIT A REPORT THAT RECOMMENDS
FUTURE COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGIES
AIMED AT ADDRESSING CHALLENGES
FACED BY WORKING FAMILIES IN
ACCESSING FLEXIBLE, AFFORDABLE
AND QUALITY CHILD CARE OPTIONS.
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE IS
UNFORTUNATELY OUT OF REACH FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS. TOO MANY
FAMILIES CONTINUE TO FALL
THROUGH THE CARE GAPS, CARE GAPS
AND, WITH JUST ABOUT 14% OF THE
STATE'S ELIGIBLE INFANTS AND
TODDLERS HAVING ACCESS TO
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE, THERE ARE
REALLY SIGNIFICANT PORTIONS OF
FAMILIES THAT FALL VICTIM TO
WHAT IS CALLED THE CARE CLIFF.
THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE CHILD
CARE DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENS
WORKING MOTHERS, WHO OFTEN TAKE
ON CAREGIVING RESPONSIBILITIES
WHEN FAMILIES CANNOT FIND OR
EVEN AFFORD CARE. HOWEVER I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A GREAT
NEED TO CHANGE THE NARRATIVE
THAT CHILD CARE IS NOT ONLY A
SOCIAL OR WOMEN'S ISSUE, BUT IS
AN ECONOMIC IMPERATIVE FOR THE
GROWTH OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CHILD CARE IS A
POLICY ISSUE THAT CUTS ACROSS
MANY OF THE AREAS, SUCH AS
PUBLIC INTEREST, INCLUDING
WORKFORCE PARTICIPATION,
ECONOMIC MOBILITY, PUBLIC
HEALTH, AND EVEN ENERGY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT IS WHY WE
HAVE TO EXPLORE. WE MUST EXPLORE
THE NEED FOR RENEWED INVESTMENTS
IN CHILD CARE AND SOLUTIONS
AIMED AT TACKLING CHILD CARE
CRISIS. THE CHILD CARE CRISIS
HEAD ON. THERE'S BEEN PLENTY OF
INCREDIBLE, AND I DO WANT TO
NOTE INCREDIBLE AND CRITICAL
WORK THAT OUR STATE HAS ALREADY
DONE AND CONTINUES TO DO,
NAMELY, IF I COULD, IT WOULD BE
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION AND
THE GOVERNOR'S MASTER PLAN ON
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION. BUT
THINGS HAVE REALLY DRASTICALLY
CHANGED SINCE COVID 19 PANDEMIC,
AND THERE HASN'T YET BEEN A
THOROUGH REVIEW ON THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT ON WORKING FAMILIES. SO,
GIVEN THE BUDGETARY CHANGES AND
THE POTENTIAL FOR MORE NEXT YEAR
AS WE'RE FACING IT, WE NEED A
POST-COVID REVIEW AND
STAKEHOLDER CONVENING THAT
REVISITS THE CURRENT POTENTIAL
POLICIES UNDER THE NEW REALITY
OF OUR STATE DEFICIT AND THE
CHANGING ECONOMICS FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES, AND
ADDRESSING CHILD CARE.
AFFORDABILITY HELPS BUILD A
COMPETITIVE ECONOMY AND NEW WAYS
OF APPROACHING THE CARE CRISIS
IS BOTH BENEFICIAL FOR FAMILIES,
VITAL FOR BUSINESS, AND CRITICAL
TO THE RECOVERY OF CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY. AS THE STATE GOES OR
MOVES THROUGH THIS MULTI YEAR
BUDGET DEFICIT. I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I AM CURRENTLY
WORKING TO STRENGTHEN THE
LANGUAGE OF AB 2774 TO CLARIFY
THAT THE INTENT OF THE BILL, TO
CLARIFY THE INTENT OF THE BILL,
BUT ALSO TO ENSURE THAT THE BILL
IS COMPLEMENTARY TO EXISTING
WORK AND NOT DUPLICATIVE. SO
WITH ME, AND THROUGH THE CHAIR,
WE DO HAVE A WITNESS HERE TODAY.
DENEEN COBURN, CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THRIVING FAMILIES
CALIFORNIA, WELCOME. AND YOU'LL
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO PRESENT
OKAY. PERFECT. THANK YOU, CHAIR,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS DENEEN COBURN, CEO OF
THRIVING FAMILIES CALIFORNIA.
FOR OVER 20 YEARS I HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE IMPLEMENTATION,
EVALUATION, STRENGTHENING
EROSION OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILD
CARE AND NOW THE REBUILDING OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD CARE. KUDOS
TO YOUR STAFF, WHO DID AN
AMAZING JOB LAYING OUT THE
HISTORY, AS WELL AS PAST WORK
THAT HAS BEEN DONE IN THIS AREA.
AS YOUR ANALYSIS NOTES, THERE
HAVE BEEN NUMEROUS WORK GROUPS,
MASTER PLANS, THE 2019 BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION, AND MORE
ATTESTING TO THE VALUE OF
ACCESSIBLE CHILD CARE TO THE
LIVES OF FAMILIES, AS WELL AS
THE LONG TERM OUTCOME THAT
QUALITY CHILD CARE HAS ON THE
LIVES OF KIDS. HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT DONE ENOUGH
TO BUILD ON THE CONNECTION OF A
STRONG, VIABLE FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDER, BUSINESS AND CENTER
WORKFORCE, AND THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT IT DIRECTLY HAS ON
BUSINESSES, JOB GROWTH AND
THRIVING ECONOMY. STUDIES HAVE
NOTED THAT FOR EVERY DOLLAR THAT
IS INVESTED IN CHILD CARE, 7 TO
$13 GOES BACK INTO THE ECONOMY.
AB 2774 CONNECTS THE DOTS AND
ASPIRES TO CREATE A FRAMEWORK
THAT BUILDS UPON, NOT
DUPLICATES, PREVIOUS WORK. IT IS
FURTHER OUR BELIEF THAT THIS
BILL WILL PUT A MAGNIFIER ON THE
CRUCIAL NEED TO SUPPORT CHILD
CARE ACCESSIBLE BY FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA'S 24 HOUR, SEVEN DAY
A WEEK ECONOMY. FAMILIES NEED
THIS, AS DO EMPLOYERS, TO
SUPPORT JOB GROWTH, ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND A HEALTHY
ECONOMY. WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
THEIR SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MISS MADAM CHAIR. EXCUSE ME AND
SENATORS ROSANNA CARVACHO
ELLIOTT HERE, ON BEHALF OF THE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. JUSTIN GARRETT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. JUSTIN BOWERS WITH CLEAN
EARTH FOR KIDS.ORG STRONGLY
SUPPORTS. IN ADDITION, NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND THE
NCCA ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD
TODAY? MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
OKAY. SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING
THE CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. HAVE, SENATOR FLAKE
HERE. THANK YOU. YES, THIS IS A
GREAT BILL, I THINK, TO CHANGE
THE NARRATIVE ON CHILD CARE. WE
DO NEED TO HAVE EMPLOYERS
INVOLVED AND WE NEED TO CENTER
IT IN AN ECONOMIC SPACE INSTEAD
OF JUST A FAMILY SPACE. SO I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU,
FOCUSING ON GO-BIZ AND NOT, NOT
SUGGESTING MOVING IT TO ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT. I THINK THAT THAT'S
REALLY THE RIGHT CALL AND
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE NEW
IDEAS SO THAT WE CAN REALLY
FIGURE THIS OUT. SO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE BILL AND I'M HAPPY
TO MOVE IT. GREAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OKAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WANTED TO JUST
KIND OF UNPACK THE, STRATEGY
BEHIND HOUSING THIS AND GO-BIZ.
SO HELP ME UNDERSTAND KIND OF
WHERE WHERE THAT GOAL IS, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION.
AND AS WAS ALREADY STATED BY
YOUR COLLEAGUE ON THE COMMITTEE
HERE, AND ALSO FROM THE FACT
THAT I COME FROM A LENS OF BEING
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION, HAVING OVER
TWO DECADES OF PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION, THÀNH AND I SAW THE
EFFECTS OF, OF OUR EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION CRISIS MOVE
US. AND TRYING TO ADDRESS IT
THROUGH THE SINGULAR OR SILOED
LENS OF A SOCIAL LENS AND NOT
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION THE
INPUT OF BUSINESS AND WORK. AND
THEN TO SEE THE COMMISSION AND
ALL OF THE GOOD WORK THAT THE
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION CAME OUT
WITH AND THE STRATEGY OF THE
GOVERNOR. AND THAT WAS ALL A
REALLY GREAT EFFORT. AND THEN
THE PANDEMIC HIT, RIGHT? I LIVED
THROUGH THAT PANDEMIC WITH THIS
EXPERIENCE OF SEEING, EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION BEING
IMPACTED IN A HUGE WAY. WE'RE
STILL RECOVERING. WE ARE STILL
IN HUGE RECOVERY MODE IN THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION SPHERE
. SO WITH THAT, IT IS, GOOD. AND
IF I MAY REFERENCE WHAT ACTIONS
AND STATEMENTS BASED ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL LEVEL, DECISION
MAKERS SUCH AS SECRETARY GINA
RAIMONDO RAIMONDO OF THE US
DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE, INSISTED
THAT THE COUNTRY NEEDS TO CHANGE
THE NARRATIVE. AND SO THIS IS
KIND OF THE IMPETUS OF WHERE IT
ALL CAME FROM. THAT CHILD CARE
IS ONLY A SOCIAL OR WOMEN'S
ISSUE. BUT IS AN ECONOMIC
IMPERATIVE FOR THE GROWTH OF THE
COUNTRY. SO BY PARKING THIS INTO
GO-BIZ, IT BRINGS BUSINESS AND
THE ECONOMY INTO THE
CONVERSATION SO THAT NOT THAT WE
NEEDED ANYTHING MORE TO
LEGITIMIZE THE CONVERSATION. BUT
THIS SURE DOES MAKE IT MORE
SUBSTANTIVE. AND IT BRINGS
PEOPLE INTO THE CONVERSATION.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN WAY EARLIER.
AND, WITH THAT, I BELIEVE GO-BIZ
WOULD BE A GREAT PARTNER. IT
DOESN'T PRECLUDE THE FACT THAT
THEY CAN'T GO OUT AND INVOLVE
OTHER STATE AGENCIES AS WELL AS,
YOU KNOW, OTHER CONTRACTORS THAT
CAN DO A THOROUGH REPORT. OKAY,
GREAT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE US? THAT WAS MY CLOSE.
THAT WAS YOUR CLOSE OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. DO I HAVE A MOTION? I'LL
MOVE. OKAY. SENATOR BLAKESLEE,
WE HAVE A MOTION. SENATOR BLAKE
FARRELL, ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLE. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE OCHOA. BOGH. OKOBOJI I
BLAKE. SPEAR. I BLAKE. SPEAR. I.
HURTADO. HURTADO. I MENGIBAR.
AND JAFAR I WE HAVE EYES ARE
FIVE ZERO NOES. THAT BILL IS
OUT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE
ONE MORE BILL TO BE HEARD TODAY.
ITEM NUMBER 17, ASSEMBLY BILL
2802. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. WELCOME OKAY. ANY
WITNESSES WITH YOU HERE TODAY?
OKAY. THANK YOU. WELCOME. WE'LL
HAVE YOU GO AHEAD AND JOIN US
HERE AT THE TABLE AND BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
HERE VERY PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
2802, WHICH SEEKS TO CREATE MORE
GENDER INCLUSIVE OPTIONS FOR
HOUSING ARRANGEMENTS WITHIN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PLACEMENT
PROGRAMS OR THP PROGRAMS. THP
PROGRAMS SERVE AS A LIFELINE FOR
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
OVER THE AGE OF 18 SUFFERING
FROM HOMELESSNESS, OFFERING THEM
TEMPORARY RELIEF AND CRUCIAL
SUPPORT SERVICES TAILORED TO
THEIR NEEDS. HOWEVER, WHEN
IMPLEMENTING THESE PROGRAMS,
PROVIDERS OFTEN ENCOUNTER
CHALLENGES IN PLACING YOUTH
STEMMING FROM EXCLUSIONARY AND
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES PRESENT
IN CERTAIN COUNTIES. THESE
CHALLENGES ARISE FROM RIGID,
BINARY GENDER BASED RULES FOR
HOUSING ARRANGEMENTS. WE MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARSH REALITIES
FACED BY MANY TRANSGENDER,
GENDER NON-CONFORMING,
NON-BINARY, AND INTERSEX
INDIVIDUALS IN THE STATE.
CURRENTLY, THE DESIGNATION OF
HOUSING VACANCIES AS MALE AND
FEMALE CREATES BARRIERS FOR
INDIVIDUALS, SIBLINGS, AND
CO-PARENTING YOUTH WHO WISH TO
LIVE TOGETHER BUT WHO DO NOT
SHARE THE SAME GENDER IDENTITY.
AB 2802 AIMS TO RECTIFY THESE
DISPARITIES BY ALLOWING FOSTER
YOUTH AND TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
TO SHARE ROOMS WITH ROOMMATES,
SIBLINGS, OR CO-PARENTS WHO DO
NOT SHARE THE SAME GENDER
IDENTITY WITH THE APPROVAL OF
THE PROVIDER ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS. BY ENABLING SIBLINGS AND
CO-PARENTING YOUTH TO ROOM
TOGETHER, WE STRENGTHEN FAMILY
BONDS AND PROVIDE A MORE
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR THOSE
WHO NEED IT MOST. IN DOING SO,
THIS BILL PROMOTES FLEXIBILITY
AND GENDER IDENTIFICATION FOR
ROOM ASSIGNMENTS, ACCOMMODATING
THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS,
IRRESPECTIVE OF THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY OR EXPRESSION. THIS
BILL IS ABOUT UPHOLDING THE
VALUE OF COMPASSION, INCLUSIVITY
AND EQUITY. BY SUPPORTING THIS
BILL, WE TAKE A SIGNIFICANT STEP
TOWARDS CREATING A MORE JUST
SOCIETY WHERE EVERY INDIVIDUAL,
REGARDLESS OF THEIR GENDER,
GENDER IDENTITY, FEELS VALUED
AND SUPPORTED AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND YOU'LL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. PAUL BHATTACHARJEE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES. WE
REPRESENT 165 DIFFERENT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, SOME OF
WHICH RUN TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PLACEMENT PROGRAMS FOR CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH,
TYPICALLY OVER THE AGE OF 18, TO
HELP THEM THRIVE INTO ADULTHOOD.
BY PROVIDING NECESSARY LIFE
SKILLS TRAINING AND HOUSING. THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB 2802, WHICH ALLOWS
FOR GENDER FLEXIBILITY IN THESE
TPS. THESE PROGRAMS SERVE A
DIVERSE POPULATION OF YOUTH,
INCLUDING LGBTQ PLUS YOUTH, AS
WELL AS PREGNANT AND
CO-PARENTING YOUTH. ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA CHILD WELFARE
INDICATORS PROJECT, ABOUT 30% OF
FOSTER YOUTH IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ
PLUS, ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
FOSTER YOUTH INSTITUTE, ALMOST
60% OF GIRLS IN FOSTER CARE
BECOME PREGNANT BY THE AGE OF
19. DESPITE THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
THIS POPULATION, SOME COUNTIES
REQUIRE PARTICIPANTS TO BE OF
THE SAME GENDER WHEN SHARING A
UNIT TOGETHER. THIS POSES
DIFFICULTIES FOR GENDER
EXPANSIVE YOUTH CO-PARENTS WHO
WISH TO RAISE A CHILD TOGETHER,
AND SIBLINGS WHO ARE OF
DIFFERENT GENDERS. THIS BILL WAS
INSPIRED BY LEVI NUNEZ, A TRANS
MALE AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
A DHP WHO HAD TO IDENTIFY AS
FEMALE HIS GENDER ASSIGNED AT
BIRTH TO AVOID HOMELESSNESS. BY
CONTINUING TO ALLOW THIS
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICE OF NOT
ALLOWING PROVIDERS TO PLACE
PARTICIPANTS TOGETHER REGARDLESS
OF GENDER, SIBLEY AND
CO-PARENTING PARTNERS WILL ALSO
CONTINUE TO BE FORCED TO
SEPARATE AND NOT ALLOWED TO LIVE
TOGETHER, SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT THE SAME GENDER. THUS,
BY IMPLEMENTING A POLICY
STATEWIDE THAT ALLOWS FOR
PROVIDERS AND PARTICIPANTS TO
JOINTLY DECIDE ON THE BEST
PLACEMENT AND ROOMMATE OPTIONS
FOR THE YOUTH ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS, REGARDLESS OF GENDER. WE
WILL BE ABLE TO BETTER
ACCOMMODATE THE NEEDS FOR ALL
YOUTH IN THESE PROGRAMS. FOR
THESE REASONS, THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE URGES AN AYE VOTE ON AB
2022. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
CRAIG PULSIPHER, ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. KELLY
MCMILLAN WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS.
THANK YOU, KIM LEWIS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YOUTH AND ASPIRING, IT AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, KRISTIN
POWER ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OKAY. ANY LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION THAT WOULD LIKE TO
BE HEARD? OKAY. SEEING NONE, ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION. OKAY. WE'LL MOVE THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS FOR OUR AUTHOR.
SENATOR CHO WITH A QUESTION. AND
I HEARD A MOTION FROM SENATOR
BLAKE SPARE. I HAVE A QUESTION
BASED ON WHAT I UNDERSTOOD AS
THE BILL IS INTENDED. ARE THERE
ANY, ANY PARAMETERS OF SAFETY,
OR. I PROBABLY SHOULD START
WITH, WHAT ARE THE CURRENT
SAFETY STANDARDS? IS, THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE, OLDER YOUTH WITH
YOUNGER YOUTH, IN. OKAY, LET ME
JUST BE FRANK. I'M REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT, HAVING OLDER
YOUTH WITH VERY YOUNG YOUTH, IN
THE SAME ROOM. JUST BASED ON,
EXAMPLES OR STORIES THAT I'VE
HEARD OF, ALMOST. I CAN'T THINK
OF ANYTHING OTHER THAN
INCESTUOUS, RELATIONS. AND
ENSURING THAT WE'RE PROTECTING
THE MINORS WITH FROM OLDER, FROM
OLDER. I'LL LET MY WITNESS
ANSWER THAT IF SHE'D LIKE. BUT
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT THAT'S
NOT WHAT THIS THIS DOESN'T
CHANGE WHAT YOU'RE EXPRESSING.
WHAT THIS WOULD ALLOW IS ONE A
FURTHER OPTION. IT'D STILL BE A
CASE BY CASE BASIS. IT DOESN'T
CHANGE ANYTHING IN EXISTING LAW.
THAT WOULD MAKE SURE THAT WHAT I
GET AT INDIVIDUALS THAT YOU'RE
CONCERNED NEED PROTECTION WOULD
BE PROTECTED. SO WHAT DO WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN LAW? WHAT IS
CURRENT LAW. SO CURRENTLY WE
HAVE TWO DIFFERENT KINDS OF
PROGRAMS. THE THP NMD PROGRAM
WHICH IS NON-MINOR DEPENDENT. SO
IT'S A COMPLETELY SEPARATE
PROGRAM FROM THE MINORS, AND SO
THOSE NMDS TYPICALLY, HAVE A
STAFF EITHER ON SITE 24 SEVEN OR
STAFF DEFINITELY CHECKING IN
VERY OFTEN, IT'S ALSO REGULATED
BY CDSS, AND SO MAKING SURE
THAT, SAFETY IS A PRIORITY,
THERE'S DEFINITELY A LOT OF
ALREADY OVERSIGHT, IN THOSE
PROGRAMS AS WELL, BY HAVING THE
STAFF ON SITE AS WELL. AND THEN
SEPARATELY, THE THP MINOR
PROGRAM VERY SMALL PROGRAM,
TYPICALLY FOR 16 AND 17 YEAR
OLDS WHO ARE ON TRACK TO
EMANCIPATE THEMSELVES, AND SO
USUALLY PROVIDERS PAIR UP 16
YEAR OLDS WITH OTHER 16 YEAR
OLDS. AND THERE'S A STAFF
REQUIRED TO BE ON SITE 24 SEVEN.
AND IN PRACTICE, USUALLY THE
YOUTH HAS A ROOM TO THEMSELVES
IN THOSE PROGRAMS BECAUSE THE
IDEA IS TO HELP PREPARE THEM FOR
ADULTHOOD AND SO IN ORDER TO
HAVE THEIR OWN SPACE, THEY
DEFINITELY PRIORITIZE THAT AS
WELL. OKAY. THANK YOU. OKAY. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS? COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
BREAKSPEARE ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLE. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. ALVARADO
GIL. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. OKAY, SO WE HAVE
FOUR AYES. ZERO NOS. THAT BILL
IS OUT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE NOW GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL. WE WILL GO THROUGH THE
ITEMS ONCE BEFORE WE CLOSE UP
THE HEARING FOR TODAY. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. CAN WE START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THEN GO
DOWN THE LINE? CONSENT CALENDAR.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. HURTADO. HURTADO.
AYE OKAY. THAT'S. AYES FIVE
ZERO. KNOWS THAT BILL IS OUT OR
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT. ADOPTED
FILE ITEM ONE AB 311 Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL. NOT VOTING AKABOGU
WAS THERE. WAS THERE A MOTION ON
THAT ONE? YEAH, IT'S Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATION. WHO CALLED THE
MOTION? OH. I'M SORRY. THAT'S
OKAY. OH, GOSH. OKAY. THIS ONE
IS AB 311. YEAH, IT'S ITEM ONE.
YEAH. SO I DON'T THINK ANYONE
WAS HERE FOR. SO LET'S WE HAVE
SEVERAL BILLS. SO LET'S CALL FOR
A MOTION. IF THERE WAS A MOTION,
THE OKAY MOVED BY SENATOR TODO,
ITEM NUMBER ONE. OKAY. FILE ITEM
ONE AB 311 DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ALVARADO GIL.
NOT VOTING. OCHOA. BOGH BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
HURTADO HURTADO. AYE. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE OKAY. EYES. THREE
NOES. ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM TWO. AB 722 DO PASS AS
AMENDED. OKAY. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? I'M SORRY. IS IT SEVEN
SEVEN 2 OR 7 22772. YEAH MOVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THANK YOU. ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. HURTADO
HURTADO. AYE. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR.
AYE. AYES. FIVE. NO ZERO. THAT
BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM FOUR AB
1967. DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WE NEED A MOTION MOTION BY BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. OKAY, SO OUR
MOTION IS DO PASS DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO. GIL Ã. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. OCHOA BOGUE. AYE OCHOA.
WAS. WAS THAT AN AYE? 96. OKAY.
I'LL. I'LL DO NOT. OKAY. XIAOBO.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR BLAKE. SPEAR.
AYE. HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE SO WE'VE
GOT FIVE AYES, ZERO NOS. THAT
BILL IS OUT. MOTION. YEAH. GO
AHEAD AND READ IT AND I'LL ASK
FOR A MOTION. OKAY. FILE ITEM
SIX AB 2317. DO PASS TO
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION? DID YOU SAY
WHO THE BILL AND WHO THE AUTHOR
IS? THE AUTHOR IS STEPHANIE
NGUYEN. YEAH OKAY. YOU MOVE IT.
MOTION BY SENATOR. ALVARADO GIL
A ALVARADO GIL. AYE. OCHOA. BOGH
A AKABOGU. AYE. BLAKE SPEER, A
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. HURTADO
HURTADO. AYE. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR
AYE. OKAY. AYES FIVE ZERO. NO.
ZERO. THAT GOES OUT. FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB 1817. DO PASS TO
HOUSING COMMITTEE. BEFORE YOU DO
THAT ONE. I GOT TO TAKE A MOTION
SO THAT ONE HAD TO MOVE. YEAH.
WHO ALREADY? WELL, WE ALREADY
DID THAT ONE. I'M SORRY. NO
THAT'S OKAY. WE JUST NEED TO
KNOW WHO MOVED IT. XIAOBO. OKAY
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO THE MOTION
IS BY OCHOA. BOGUE OKAY. AND THE
VOTE WAS CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE FIVE ZERO OUT. BILL
IS FIVE AYES, ZERO NOS. THAT
BILL IS OUT. OKAY AND THEN ON
THIS ONE I DON'T KNOW. SO THE
BILL AND THE AUTHOR AND WOLF
OKAY. FILE ITEM NINE AB 1911 DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THAT MOTION WAS MADE
BY. BLAKESPEAR. THANK YOU. YOU
JUST CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS,
PLEASE. OKAY. THAT WOULD BE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
FIVE ZERO OUT. ALL RIGHT. SO WE
HAVE EYES. FIVE NOES, ZERO. THAT
BILL IS OUT. THEN DO YOU KNOW
WHO MOVED THIS ONE? SHAKESPEARE.
SHAKESPEARE. THANK YOU. YEAH
OKAY. I DIDN'T KNOW I HAD TO
WRITE THAT. SORRY. GOOD FILE
ITEM 11 AB 1947 Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIR.
THE MOTION WAS MADE BY SENATOR
BLAKE BLAKE SPEAR, MOTION CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. HURTADO HURTADO. AYE. FIVE
AYES ZERO NOS. THAT BILL IS OUT.
OKAY. AND 2383. OKAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY. FILE ITEM 13 AB 2383 Dð
PASS TO HEALTH COMMITTEE. MOTION
MADE BY SENATOR OCHOA. BOGH
CHAIR. VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. HURTADO. HURTADO.
AYE FIVE. NO. OUT. AYES. FIVE.
NOES ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT.
OKAY AND THEN 24. TEN AND FOUR.
FILE ITEM 14 AB 2410. DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. MÐI THÀNH VÌ MENGIBAR.
HURTADO. HURTADO I AYES FIVE
ZERO. NO. ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT
. OKAY. ALMOST THERE. OVER HERE
ON THAT ONE. OKAY. FILE ITEM 17
AB 3217 DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THAT
WAS MOVED BY BLAKE SPEER. CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE AYES
FIVE. NO ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT.
MENGIBAR. OH, I'M SORRY, I
DIDN'T VOTE ON THAT. THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. YES. SORRY ABOUT THAT.
ALL RIGHT. OH, I DO HAVE TO
RECALL IT BECAUSE I ALREADY
CALLED IT OUT. YEAH. OKAY SO
JUST REDO THE VOTE. SHE HAS TO
DO A MOTION. NO I ALREADY CALLED
IT OUT. MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION. YOUR MOTION?
YEAH. OKAY. DO YOU HAVE A MOTION
FOR RECONSIDERATION ON FILE
NUMBER 17? ASSEMBLY BILL 3217.
CAN I CALL MY OWN? I'M. YOU
CAN'T MOTION FOR MYSELF, CAN
YOU? OKAY, I MOVE IT. OKAY MOVED
BY SENATOR BLAKE. BLAKE SPEER,
THIS VOTE IS ON THE
RECONSIDERATION, NOT ON THE
BILL. SO CALL THE ROLL. OKAY.
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ALVARADO.
GIL AYE. OCHOA. BOGUE. AKABOGU.
AYE BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE HURTADO. HURTADO AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE OKAY,
NOW CALL THE BILL. OKAY FILE
ITEM 17 AB 33217. DO PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. MOVED
BY MOVED BY. MOVE THE BILL BLAKE
SPEER BY BLAKE SPEER. YEP. OKAY.
CALL THE ROLL. ABSENT MEMBERS,
PLEASE. OKAY OKAY, I HAVE TO
CALL EVERYONE. OKAY. ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE. ALVARADO GIL. AYE.
OKOBO. OKOBO AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR.
AYE. AYE. IS FIVE NOES. ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT. OKAY AND THEN
WHICH ONE WAS THIS? 39. RIGHT
HERE. BLAKE. SPEER. OKAY. FILE
ITEM 21 AB 2929. DO PASS IS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY MOVED BY
BLAKE SPEER CHAIR VOTING AYE.
OCHOA BOGUE. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. Ã CHOBOQ. BODIE OKAY.
HURTADO AYE. HURTADO. AYE SO
THAT ONE IS FOUR ZERO OUT. AYES
FOUR. NO ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT.
OKAY. 3229. THEY NEED WE NEED A
MOTION BECAUSE. OH THIS ONE WE
DIDN'T DO YET. I'M SORRY OKAY.
WE NEED A MOTION ON THIS ONE. DO
YOU WANT ME TO JUST CALL IT. AND
THEN WE'LL DO A MOTION OKAY.
COOL. FILE ITEM 22 AB 3229. DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. I NEED A MOTION. WILL
THE BILL MOTION CALLED BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. THANK YOU.
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALVARADO. GIL AYE. ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE. AKABOGU. AKABOGU AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
HURTADO HURTADO. AYE. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR AYE. OKAY. EYES ARE
FIVE. NOES ARE ZERO. THAT BILL
IS OUT. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO OUR
STAFF. AND THANK YOU, MEMBERS,
WE ARE NOW GOING TO ADJOURN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES AND HAVE A GREAT
EVENING.